what is up how's it going disses Kazi
from clever programmer calm what I
wanted to cover in this series is Django
and what I wanted to cover was like the
most commonly referenced Django
documentation I personally couldn't
really find any videos of people like
covering it so I just wanted to do that
because you know I see like everybody
who starts learning Django this is the
first place you're gonna go to like the
docs the Django official documentation
that shows you how to you know do their
getting started guide and so I just want
to kind of cover that in this series and
just right now I just want to kind of
cover the overview and then we're gonna
jump into actually the parts of the
tutorial okay and you're just gonna
follow me along alright so I'm gonna
cover this kind of touch on this so if
you have some experience with it it will
make a little bit of sense so designing
your models so in Django you can kind of
design your database and models like
this you don't need to type in raw
sequel queries or mess with too many or
ORM s it's just simply classes so it's
literally like Python and
object-oriented programming and boom you
have stuff populating your database
which is pretty cool it also has a built
in kind of API so it says you know as
soon as your models are done the API is
created on the fly no code generation
necessary okay so here you can see that
if you create a model like let's say
that you're creating an app right and
has reporters and your app has articles
you know well what you can just do is
just be like hey reporter that objects
at all and I'll tell you how many
reporters are there for example if you
made a game app for like let's a street
fighter and you did fighter dot objects
at all it might say empty set which
means you didn't put in any fighters yet
right but then let's say you create a
fighter or a reporter with the name John
Smith and you save it then when you
check objects at all all of a sudden
they'll say hey reporter John Smith
actually does exist so
that's pretty cool and a really nice way
to interface with it and then also you
can search for things in a really easy
way to so you can search in your
database with an ID but you know a lot
of the times more human way to search
instead of an ID is like searching with
what does the name start with or if the
name contains the word myth which Smith
actually contains and it'll match it so
then what you can do on your front-end
later is right now like you're not gonna
have your client interface with your app
from the code command line right what
you can do later is then give them a
front-end and interface so then they can
actually type it in the search bar and
look up John Smith or type in myth and
you'll still find John Smith kind of
like when you guys go to like Shopify
stores or you know YouTube and type in a
video's name and even if you're off
you'll still find it it's using this
contained search mechanism which Jango
comes built in with another thing I want
to touch on is yeah so if you have your
model you can register them in the admin
interface but just a simple line that
says admin dot side that register and
then that model votes lets you create
the article model you can now register
it an admin interface so then you can go
and point and click in an admin
interface and then delete or create new
articles or whatnot right for example
when you have a wordpress blog you know
how you have an admin interface there
and you can create a new blog post or
delete a post or edit you have full crud
functionality well that's what it mimics
by you just doing this right and that's
you creating code from scratch that's
kind of powerful and then obviously lets
you design your URLs right so how do you
want your URLs to be so for example you
can have it like you know my AB com
slash articles slash the year followed
by whatever right so you can create your
own URL parameters and whatever so this
is pretty standard but it looked Django
lets you do it in a really clean way
especially with django 2.0 there are new
latest release alright so
writing your views is also pretty easy
you can have it just like return HTTP
response or HTML file you made so for
example here you can see we render and
return like this archive HTML file so if
you create a HTML file in your templates
then it's gonna be there again if you're
watching this and you're like I'm a
complete beginner and I have no idea
what the heck you're talking about don't
worry if this part is just not making
any sense skip a little bit ahead to the
part where we jump into the tutorial
this is just for people who are maybe
coming from other frameworks and they
want to grasp how Python and Django is
working ok so you do need some
experience to understand what I'm
talking about here and then yeah
templates are using it's it's using
Django templates which is kind of like
Jinja I'll go into this later so at this
point like let's just get started
alright so for your installation all you
really need to do is make sure you have
Python installed so for myself I got
anaconda installed which is out which is
what I would recommend for you so if you
do anaconda download online kind of
install that and that's pretty much all
you need to go on and then obviously
install django as well which i'll show
you in one second ok alright and then
you can go ahead and create a project so
we're gonna just get started from
scratch and follow along with this
tutorial so let's let's get started ok
so I'm gonna open up my command line
here so I'm just gonna open up my
terminal if you're watching this you can
open up your you know CMD on Windows or
what I recommend installing is CMD ER on
your windows and yeah basically just see
if you have anaconda installed and if
you do and if you type in Conda dish
this thing should come up ok if you
don't have anaconda installed that's ok
you can still follow me along but what
i'm doing here is kind of like for best
practice so if you want to do it like
the best
back this way then I recommend that you
get Conda installed here let me just min
make this a little bit smaller all right
so basically what I want to do here is
first check my chain so what I'm gonna
do is install my environment with Conda
okay so I'm gonna do and and again
installing anaconda and like making you
understand everything about virtual
environments is outside the scope of
this specific tutorial so you can look
up stuff like how to install anaconda on
Windows or how to install anaconda on a
Mac but I'm just gonna go ahead and do
Conda or first I'm gonna create this
project so let's see I'm gonna go to my
github alright what I've also done is I
have gone into preferences in my Adam
and I have went in under install and
I've installed terminal platform meal
ide terminal and I've installed it so
then the beauty of that is that when I'm
coding right if I'm coding I can just
pop open my terminal right in here and I
don't have to leave my Adam so I will do
Django admin start project my site like
that and then go into my site okay and
then I will come over here and I will
open I'll go to github and then I'll go
my site and then just click that okay
that's about it this is just so if you
guys are following along like I don't
want you to get confused okay I'm gonna
open up my chrome so they're saying that
this is pretty much what it should look
like and for us it does look like that
right we have my site and it has all
these files inside of it and you can see
my site and it has all these files
inside of that okay and then they say
hey just go ahead and run Python manage
that py run sir
so let's go ahead and give that a try so
I'm gonna open up my terminal and how I
do that how I open up that little prompt
is by doing command shift P for you on
Windows that might be a different
command like maybe control shift P but
yet for me that opens it up and then I
just click terminal pops open my
terminal I'm gonna do kondeh create - -
name my sites Python is equal to 3.6 and
I will activate this environment okay
and now I will install Django okay so if
I do pip freeze it should show me that
Django and bunch other stuff is
installed
Django right here so we're good all
right I'm just gonna make the fonts
bigger so you guys can see it a lot
easier okay so now we're gonna try to
run this Python manage that py run
server and we will go to this URL on our
chrome and see if it shows us something
okay cool
so it says install work successfully
congratulations and believe it or not
this is actually pretty exciting because
this is the first hint that your app is
actually running okay now to this we're
gonna add a lot more features to it and
make it really awesome but right now
it's being actually served over your
localhost and it's running okay and once
we get it to a point where it's doing a
lot of cool stuff we'll develop it
locally and then later on well you can
even do is then put it online so then
anybody in the world can use your django
app
let's go back and let's take a look at
what the tutorial is telling us to do at
this point so it says that you should
see this stuff and we do and then it
says ignore the warning about unapplied
database migrations for now we'll deal
with the database shortly cool
and it says we we have started a Django
development server which is a
lightweight web server written purely in
Python we've included this with Django
so you can develop things rapidly
without having to deal with configuring
a production server such as Pachi until
you're ready for production cool alright
and they say don't use the server in
anything resembling a production
environment ended for developing cool no
problem alright and now they want us to
get started on creating the pulls pulls
app now that your environment a project
is set up you're set to start doing work
each application you write in Django
consists of a pure or of a Python
package that follows a certain
convention Django comes with a utility
that automatically generates the basic
directory structure of an app so you can
focus on writing code rather than
creating directories cool alright
projects versus apps so what's the
difference between a project and an app
now the cool thing with Django is that
everything is considered an app ok so
let's say that you create a website that
has a blog that has an e-commerce
capability now the blog is considered a
so let's say you create this website
with Django write the blog would be
considered a jingle app and your
ecommerce store would actually be
considered a different Django app ok so
there'd be two different apps that your
web application is comprised of that's
how Django handles the logic so
basically it's one project that has
multiple apps inside of it ok that's
pretty much what they're saying here ok
so an app is a web application that does
something ok so a web blog system a
database of public records or simple
poll
a project is a collection of
configuration apps for a particular
website a project can contain multiple
apps an app can mean multiple projects
so you can have one app that you build
for one project and you can actually
have it in different projects that
you're doing which is really cool
it's like plug and chug your apps can
live anywhere on your Python path in
this tutorial we will create our poll
app right next year manage that py file
so that it can be imported as its own
top-level module rather than a sub
module of my site
okay to create your app make sure you're
in the same directory as manage type py
and type this command ok so now this
command Python manage type py start app
pulls we're gonna do that okay so we're
gonna break our server with ctrl C ok so
I did that I'm gonna hit LS and it looks
like I'm at the same level as my manage
py file and if I hit PWD PWD I'll show
me where I'm at and now I'm gonna do
Python manage that py start app and the
app is called pulls I believe just let's
just double check ok so now our polls
app is created and let's just take a
look inside of polls polls ok so inside
of polls you can see that we have a
bunch of oh actually let's look right
over here it's easier that way
so polls comes with migrations in it
that py admin apps models tests views
there's a lot of things that polls comes
up with automatically which is really
nice but a lot of this stuff is you know
just kind of empty the main things that
you're gonna be working with is models
and views okay that's a little that's
the thing you're gonna be working with
like all the time when you're developing
apps for yourself later you're also
gonna be playing around quite you're
gonna be doing adding stuff to test to
make sure you can test your app as
you're building it and then migrations
is gonna be important because it's gonna
kind of let you time travel in your data
base so when we keep making changes to
your
with migrations you can like roll
forward to a certain time but let's say
like things get really messed up you can
roll back to a previous point in time
all right so the disc directory
structure will house is a poll
application so this is the directory
structure that we actually saw okay and
now they want us to write our first view
a view is what lets you go to a specific
URL and then it returns some kind of
response okay so for example so Jango
works off of something called MVT which
is called Model View templates your
normal apps you know no GS or whatever
those frameworks work off of MVC Model
View controller so to give you an
example of this in real life is when you
go to google.com slash you know when you
go to google.com and you type in like
cats right or let's say you go to
google.com and you type in whatever the
response that comes to you right that
maps to the current URL you're at so how
does Google know to show you the Google
logo and the Google homepage when you go
to google.com right so Google calm when
you type it in it sees what your current
URL path is then it goes into the Google
code base and then it finds this HTML
file that says if somebody goes to this
path that says google.com then show them
this HTML page that has Google's image
on it followed by a search bar and then
shows you that okay it's so it returns a
response you request something and it
returns a response if you go to
apple.com slash watches or watch I don't
know if that's actually a real Apple URL
but like let's just say you're trying to
get Apple watch ok so if you go to
apple.com slash watch how would it
return to you all of their watches right
so what actually happens is apple.com
slash watch will match
that path in their code base and then
ill see if there is a HTML file that
corresponds to it and then I'll show you
that HTML file okay as a response and
that's essentially what we're gonna do
what we're gonna have a very basic
version of it so we're gonna go in our
pull slash views that py so I'm in my
polls and I'm gonna go in my views that
py so when they say it like this poll
slash use a py that's what they mean and
in here I'm gonna say from Django dot
HTTP import HTTP response right and then
I'm gonna go here I'll set the fine
index request so take in a request and
then return an HTTP response and I will
say hello world you're at let's do it
with double quotes because hello world
your understood at the polls index right
and then they have a little comma here
this doesn't matter so much it's just a
string so it doesn't matter what you do
make sure you always save what you're
doing cuz otherwise it won't take any
effect so make sure you do control last
your command s the whole time so I just
created this but the thing is that it's
not gonna show up so now what I need to
do is like tell my app that when
somebody goes to the home page yo you
got to show this exact this thing right
here okay this is the simplest view
possible in Django to call the view we
need to map it to a URL and for this we
need a URL con for a URL configuration
to create a URL conf in the polls
directory create a file called URLs that
py your app directory should now look
like this so now notice there is a URLs
that py here which was not there before
okay so we're gonna go in our polls
right click here and create a new file
and call it URLs that py okay
and now in our URLs that py we gotta add
from Jango dot URLs import path from
Jango URLs import path and then we're
gonna do from import views and then
we're gonna do URL patterns so what you
want to do is try not to indent but use
four spaces instead okay one two three
four if it doesn't automatically bring
you to the right place
all right and I want to do path so if
somebody goes to the empty path then I
want you to go into our views file and
use the index function and we're gonna
call give it a name index okay so what
does this mean if somebody goes to let's
say your website is called John comm
right somebody goes to John comm
followed by nothing else so not like
John dot-com slash article slash blog
none of that
it's just John calm your homepage what
happens well then we say going to the
views file and run the index function so
in under views
this is index function I'll run that
we're naming it index so then later if
we want to from our templates or HTML if
you want to refer to this specific URL
path we can just call it by index and
I'll reference it okay the next step is
to point the root URL configuration at
the polls that URLs module okay so
you're all conf and we gotta point it to
this so all right in my site /url that
py add an import for Django URLs include
and insert include in the URL patterns
list so you have this so we're gonna go
in our my side slash URLs right here and
in here we're gonna add this line okay
because we're saying if somebody goes to
the path polls then run the polls URLs
okay so from Django contributed man from
Jing er and port from Django died URLs
import include comma path okay and
that's because we're gonna do the
include thing right now just like that
okay and then hit save so if somebody
types in John calm slash polls now will
say hey try to match this pattern by
going to the pulls out URLs file well
where is that that's in the pulls app
and it's this file right here so then
it'll go to this file and then it'll
match this first guy and they'll say
okay I'm gonna run the home function
okay so anytime somebody goes to
anything polls they'll refer it to that
file that URLs file alright the this is
what they're basically saying here the
include function allows referencing
other URL cons whenever Django
encounters include it chops off whatever
part of the URL mash up to that point
and sends the remaining string to the
included URL can't for further
processing
the idea behind include is to make it
easy to plug-and-play URLs
since polls are in their own URL can't
they can be placed under or any path and
the app will still work okay
you have now wired so now it says you
should always include you should always
use include when you include other URL
patterns okay and now it says you have
now wired an index view into the let's
verify it's working run the following
command okay so now we're gonna run this
thing and we'll go to our localhost or
this HTTP is port over here and hit run
and now we are getting an error oh yes
basically you have to do slash polls
okay of course because it's not a home
page thing that we've added to cuz I
just saw this and I was like Oh home
page but it's because we got a
the pols path okay so everything after
so it's like when you put this online
when you put this app online right it'll
essentially be like your app comm slash
poles is where you'll have to go to and
then it'll know what to do okay so it's
saying you're at the poles index and
that's exactly what we see now cool go
to this in your browser and you should
see the text which you define in the
index the path function is packed it's
passed for arguments to required route
and view and two optional at this point
it's worth reviewing what these
arguments are for all right so we're not
gonna go into too much detail is gonna
be like still casual and we're gonna
keep moving forward
do part two of the official Django
tutorial we have already done quite a
bit of stuff right we've gone our local
servers started but what we want to do
now is in this video we're gonna
actually cover our admin interface and
we're gonna actually start playing
around with it so it's gonna be pretty
exciting I hope you're willing and
excited to see how that works okay and
we're gonna go through this one a little
bit faster so okay so first thing you
want to do is like look at the database
setup which you can frankly ignore if
you're new but later on like this is
something that you should read but for
now we're only gonna focus on this
command it says python manage that py
migrate okay so this is a complete
continuation from the last video okay so
make sure you're caught up on everything
from part one I'm gonna open up Adam and
I'm gonna break out of this by doing
ctrl C and I will do Python manage that
py migrate and it should give you a
bunch of okay's and what that did is
created these tables that weren't
created before okay so they're all
created like stuff with user names and
emails and permissions and all the stuff
that it has to do on the back end
okay alright and from here we're gonna
go on and we're gonna try to now create
models alright so we'll define your
models essentially your database layout
with some additional metadata how django
models work is their philosophy follows
the DRI principle which stands for do
not repeat yourself which is a really
common commonly used acronym in the
programming world and it emphasizes
using logic that helps you never really
repeat yourself right so for example
just to give you a simple example
imagine if you have to print out a
letter or print out the word boom 100
times you could keep writing print boom
print boom print boom or you could do it
in the dry way which
is write a for loop that prints it out
100 times okay so that way it allows you
to stop yourself from repeating and just
helps you do it at once
now when you start abstracting it and
taking it to a higher level that might
mean taking your code from basic basic
code and modularizing it into a function
or into a class or into a package things
of that nature okay and that's the same
philosophy Django goes off on so instead
of like repeating yourself over and over
again it lets you create a class which
it then creates models out of and
handles a lot of that stuff for you okay
so we're gonna create this these models
okay and basically what we're gonna be
working on in our simple poll app we're
gonna create two models question and a
choice a question has a question and a
publication date so I almost imagine
like a spreadsheet let's say you create
a new sheet in the spreadsheet and you
call it a sheet question you have column
one that says question text column two
that has a publication date so question
text on your first row might be what the
hell's going on and the publication date
may be like February whatever and your
next question might be like when is Kazi
gonna make the next piece of content
stop making all these crazy videos where
he's outside talking to the camera and
then your publication date next to it
right so that's how I want you to
picture when we create these models all
right with that said let's move on a
choice is gonna be its own spreadsheet
or its own sheet okay and basically what
it does is a choice has two fields the
text is a choice and a vote tally okay
so the check text and the vote tally and
then the question that you get to choose
it is actually referenced from the
question model okay so let's actually
now write this code out so let's go to
our polls and I'm just gonna copy pasted
it I recommend that you actually write
it out because it's really helpful
exercise for you but just for a time I'm
gonna go through it faster so we're
gonna put it I'm gonna paste it right
here okay I'm gonna save it
all right now we have to activate our
models okay so I'm going to go into my
settings my side slash settings and
inside of here I want to tell Django
that we actually have this app installed
okay so what I want to do is pulls dot
apps dot I think it's polls config like
that okay and make sure to put a comma
after it because after all it is a list
with one two three four five six seven
elements okay so now Django knows to
include the pulls app let's run another
command so up until now Django had no
idea what this thing that you created
this pulls app but now that you went in
my site and added this under settings
and added to your installed apps now it
knows that it's actually there okay it's
equivalent of kind of like let's say you
downloaded an app on your Mac or your
windows but you never installed it right
like downloaded a game but you never
installed it's kind of like that so we
just installed it by doing this okay and
now what we want to do is let's run
another command Python manage that py
make migrations polls okay so I'm gonna
come into my command line and again to
activate your virtual environment you'll
do source activate followed by the name
of your virtual environment and to
deactivate your virtual environment you
will do source deactivate if you're on a
Mac if you're on Windows then all you
need to do is activate followed by the
name of your virtual environment so in
this case it'll be my site okay so um
since I'm already activated on my
virtual environment I'm just gonna do
Python and manage that py make
migrations polls and now you see that it
says create model choice create model
question add field question to choice
okay alright by running make migrations
are telling Jango that you've made some
changes to your models in this case
you've made new ones and that you'd like
to change this to be store
that's a migration cool and this is
effectively what the sequel will look
like for this so this is not something
you have to worry about if you're a
beginner and you don't even know its
sequel is totally fine but if you have a
little bit of experience check it out
what's really cool is like bunch of this
code that you would normally add like
generally anything to do with databases
requires you to know sequel or write
sequel ok SQL and queue for you to write
raw SQL it looks pretty complicated
right like for example if you go here
there's a lot going on if you write
sequel every day may not be that big of
a deal but it's a lot going on
whereas Django it's automatically
generating all this code for you and you
don't actually even have to worry about
it I just showed it to you so you can
see what it actually looks like on the
back end so that's what they're showing
here and we're not just gonna we're not
gonna worry about that and since we made
the migrations we're gonna commit those
migrations to our database by doing
Python manage py and typing in migrate
okay so now it says applying polls
initial and it says ok if I go to my
migrations I can also see this specific
migration that I made ok and I can read
this migration whenever I want do not
mess around with this file too much
unless you know exactly what you're
doing
oh ok ok cool and now we're gonna play
with the API
another thing about migrations when you
get a little bit more advanced it allows
you to update your database without ever
losing track of it so flask has kind of
a weird migration thing going on
whereas Django kind of comes with it and
so it's database is a lot easier to play
around with like it says migrations are
very powerful let you choose your models
over time as you develop your project
without the need to delete your database
or tables and make new ones that's
generally what you have to do if you're
working with you know like just kind of
working from scratch it specializes in
upgrading your database live without
losing data so again there's gonna be
really powerful and helpful as you get
more advanced and as you do more
things with models so now let's play
around with the API that actually Django
gives to us for free
alright so we don't actually have to
write it it just kind of comes with it
so I'm gonna go and instead of just
typing in Python I'm gonna do Python
manage dot py shell okay and here I will
do from pulls on models import question
comma choice and then now we can play
around with it so since we don't have
any questions in our system yet when we
actually look up questions and the
objects for it it should show us empty
right because we didn't create any thing
from in the question model okay so if I
do this at all it should show us none
and that's exactly what it's showing us
like hey the query set is actually empty
now what we want to do is create a new
question all right
Django expects a time date use times one
two now instead of this and it'll do the
right thing okay so we're gonna go from
Django dot utils import time zone okay
and what is our question
take remember if we look in our
questions model it takes two things it
takes a question text and a publication
date and that's what we want to give it
to create a new question object okay so
pretty much type that in and what is it
saying it's saying hey I'm creating a
question object this question class
essentially takes in a few things
question text and publication date and
I'm using keyword arguments so I'm put
in question underscore text equals so
for the question text it takes in a car
field so let's go actually here in
models and you can see that it takes in
a character field right here and that's
why I'm actually passing it in as a
string and then publication date takes
in date time field and that's why I'm
passing in the time zone dot now object
okay
and she's gonna hit enter here and now
queue is created so I should be able to
do something like well let's follow
along with their documentation is saying
but if we actually do this now right
question not objects dot all let's see
if it shows us so that's because we
haven't saved this yet so once we save
it it's gonna show up in our as one of
our created objects for a question so
let's follow along so now that says save
the object into the database you have to
call save explicitly so we're gonna do
that I'm gonna say Q dot save and let's
try it again
and now look it shows us that there is
indeed one question and it even has a
number an extra at one okay but it's not
very helpful because it's not showing us
what that question is or it's not giving
us a very easily readable name when we
actually use this API so I'll show you
guys how to overcome that too all right
so now it has an ID if you do queue that
ID it'll show you its ID it says access
model field values via Python attributes
so I could do Q dot question text so
that question text right there and it'll
show us like what's new and I can do Q
dot Pub location date and it'll show me
the date as a day time object 2018 -
which is February 19th and let's go down
here and we can even change the values
by changing the attributes and then
calling save on it okay so for example
before we had the question that's what's
new we can now save that question is
what's up okay so for example I can do
queued question underscore text is equal
to what's up okay so at how and I can do
Q dot save and now if I do Q dot
question text you'll see that it
actually says what's up right
displays all the questions in the
database so now if I again do this which
you've seen it'll show me all of the
questions right now we only have one
question okay so if I wanted to add
multiple questions I could do that
you know let's say that we add q2 and
then I do q3 and then I go right over
here instead of saying what's new say
what's popping like that hit enter and
now if I do question dot objects dot all
you can see that it shows me oh sorry I
have to save Q 2 dot save Q 3 dot save
and now if I do this you'll see that it
shows me I have one question two
questions three questions and I can even
say for a question and questioned
objects dot all I can loop through it
print question dot question underscore
text like that and if I run that a loop
through all of these and then they'll
print out the question text okay so you
can do it this is just like playing
around with its API and kind of getting
comfortable with it okay and it goes
wait a minute
question isn't a helpful representation
of this object so let's fix that by
editing the question model in the thing
so that's what I was talking about right
like they're saying it in their
technical terms basically what they're
saying is like hey look this looks ugly
as hell and doesn't give us any
information like what this is about so
let's make it into something that a
human can read and be like okay I get
what this question is and it's readable
right so that's what we want to do all
we need to do is add a string method
okay so we're gonna add string
representation to it you'll see what I
mean in just a second so right now it
just shows us like blob like whatever
right well we're gonna do is under the
class question we're going
add a string method like that okay and
it's gonna take in self and then we're
gonna say a return solve that question
underscore tax like that okay so instead
of showing us this wouldn't it be nicer
if it showed us that question because
that's a much easier way of identifying
what that question is when you're just
looking at the list it's just more
readable that way okay and we're gonna
do the same thing with choice we're just
gonna go here create a function or
create a method because we're inside of
a class and I will say self and I'm
gonna say return salt self dot what do I
want to do here choice underscore text
all right and I don't think I have to
suit here let's try it okay cool so now
it's important to add string methods to
your models not only for your
convenience when dealing with
interactive prompt but also because
objects representations are used
throughout Django's automatically
generated admin so later when we go and
I show you the admin this is actually
gonna be helpful there because then when
we're reading these names the admin is
gonna be using it all the however we're
showing it in the console right now is
gonna be showing it on our admin
interface right so like imagine if you
created an app and you gave it to your
client where it's like a blogging app
right or if it's ecommerce app you don't
want them to go to the store and when
there's aren't differentiate between
items it just says item 1 item 2 item 3
item 4 it'd be much nicer if it says
like bicycle or watch or iPhone X or
whatever they're selling right it'll be
easier for them to identify that's
essentially what we're doing right here
note that these are normal Python
methods let's add a custom method just
for demonstration so they're adding a
new
method here so we're gonna do that I'm
gonna go into my models and we will
import date time at the top and then
we're also going to import time zone
oops right underneath this guy and we
will add this method under a question
okay okay so what's published recently
is a method in the question class so you
can do like Q dot was published recently
and it'll tell you what its gonna do is
gonna basically tell you true or false
okay so I think what it's checking for
is like if it was published within one
day or later than 24 hours let's see
what this say no the edition of import
and to and from Django does import time
zone to reference pythons standard
date/time mahjongg Django's time zone
related utilities respectively save
these changes and start a new Python
interactive shell by running Python
manage that py shell again now because
we didn't make any changes to the models
we just added new methods we don't have
to migrate this to our database all we
need to do just like exit out of this
shell and just like come to it again I'm
gonna do exit open closed paren and I'm
just gonna do Python manage that py
shell again and then let's see if we can
get that command
yeah front pulls out models so basically
from this file pulls dot models I'm
importing this class question and this
this model choice model both our models
classes whatever and make sure our
string our Edition is working okay so
now what we're gonna try to do is do the
same thing except this time it's not
gonna show us question whatever is gonna
actually show us the text of each
question so there you go what's up
what's new what's poppin okay much
easier for us to see this okay
so again think of it like if you had a
fighter database instead of it saying
fighter one fight or two fight or three
it show it to you as like
Ryu and like Sagat Jango provides a rich
database lookup API is entirely driven
by keyword arguments okay so you can do
something like hey I want you to filter
by where the ID is 1 so it'll give me
that specific question only or I can say
filter by ID - and it'll give me the
question that has idea of - ok
or I can filter by question text that
says new inside of it or what's new
inside of it just like it's showing me
here like if so let's try this one ok so
question text starts with what ok so
let's see so far all of these start with
the what so it's gonna show us all three
but what if I do
instead of starts with I say contains
and I say open ok there's only one
question that's a that contains that ok
then later we can provide a front-end to
our client where you can like in the
search bar type it in but on the back
end we're using this contains method to
find the exact thing that you need and
then return there's a response from our
HTML file get the question that was
published this year okay so let's get
the question was published this year
we're gonna do this we're gonna say
current year is timezone now that year
so that's gonna get basically 2018 right
if I do current year it'll say 2018 and
question that objects that get where the
publication date year is the current
year okay so let's do that get returned
more than one question it returned three
so because we have multiple questions
instead of one ours is gonna be
different than theirs very slightly ok
so four hours since it matches all of
them and gets like yo what's going on
I'm matching all of them so but nothing
to worry about it's still working for us
if you request an ID that doesn't
doesn't exist it will raise an exception
so for us we do have ID too so it won't
raise an exception but like let's say
that we try to find something with an ID
of four or five sorry we have to do dot
get it's gonna raise an exception okay
also for this let's try so what would
happen if instead of that get we use
filter would we get an error or would we
get something in return we would get
something in return which is like all of
these that match it okay so the
different difference between filter is
like return everything that matches and
yet is like get one and if more than one
match then like throw an error or
something like that okay so look up by a
primary keys the most common use case so
Jango provides a shortcut for a primary
key lookups a falling question the
following is identical to questions that
objects that get ID so PK which is a
primary key okay so every model will
have a primary key so for example
question will have a primary key choice
will have a primary key and think about
this is like let's say you have a
database with people in it right or
employee names well what if you have two
john smith employees right out of a
hundred employees or but if you have two
apple watches in your ecommerce store
that you're selling that have the same
name or two people that have the same
name how are you gonna differentiate
what if they have the same email address
or whatever right so you need one thing
that's always always always always
unique so if you can't rely on their
first name last name or email address or
whatever else one thing you can always
rely on is a primary key it could be a
automatically generated key from Python
and can be like random words or whatever
right Jango will handle the primary keys
for you everything will have a primary
key even if it doesn't show it to you on
the back end this way you can always
find
you know the unique way of referring to
something okay all right so let's go
here saying that make sure our custom
method worked
so it says cute objects I got peak it
one okay so basically what I'm gonna do
is go here and say hey get me the object
where the primary key is one and save it
as cue and now I'm gonna ask if q was
published recently okay and it says true
okay cool so that's the result we got
give the question question a couple of
choices the create call constructs a new
choice object does insert statement as
the choice is set available choice and
returns a new choice object Jango
creates a set to hold other side of
foreign key relation question show
between we access via the API alright so
we're gonna do this guy again if you
haven't done so already display any
choices from the related objects set so
we don't have any choices so far okay
we're right now basically voting for
questions kind of like you can upvote
comments on YouTube so now we're gonna
create three choices so queue that
choice set dot create so we're gonna
take a question which is our first
question which was like what's up and
we're gonna create choice text is equal
to not much with zero votes okay and you
can see choice has a field called votes
and then it has choice texts so our
first answer to that question what's up
it is not much but we're saying like
look it only has 0 votes okay
okay and now we're gonna create another
choice but called the sky what's up the
sky I mean guess that's kind of funny
I say the ceiling and then here's
another one that is and we're gonna
restore this one actually SC oh okay
there we go okay so now choice objects
have API access to their related
question objects okay so now if I do see
dot question
so even though I've created this model
from choice you know you'd be looking at
it be like hey how does it have access
to the specific question like how did it
access this field here's how I did it
because we're saying in this question go
to the foreign key and the foreign key
is this model over here when I do choice
that question it'll go and get the
question from up there
that's essentially what it's doing okay
so that's what when I do see that
question that's what's happening it's
referencing and getting me back this
object okay and vice versa so you can
also reference from question you could
reference choice question objects get
access to choice objects okay so they
both have access to each other kind of
like you can have a book and you know
like who was the author of this book so
that relation goes to the author and
then you can say like this author has
which books and it can relate back to
the books alright so now we're gonna see
how many choices we have and so we have
not much is one choice the other one we
have is the sky and then the other
choice that we have is just hacking a
again all of these have zero votes as we
see right here and we're gonna say Q dot
choice underscore set that counts so
this is just a count that there are
actually three choices the API
automatically follows relationships as
far as you need use double underscores
to separate relationships this works as
many levels deep as you want there's no
limit find all choices for any questions
whose publication date is in this year
reusing the current year variable we
created above okay so I can say choice
that objects are filter question double
underscore means like you are kind of
going backwards
so we're saying question and then we're
going publication date okay so actually
we're going this question here and then
we're going to publication date and then
checking the year getting the year of
that publication date okay
so let's try that right over here so
it's gonna get us all the questions that
are from this current year so it should
get us all three of these let's delete
one of the choices use delete for that
so now what I can say is I can get the
question that starts with just hacking
right and how do I do that I say cute a
choice set da filter by we're choice
text starts with just hacking okay so
it's only gonna get one question that
has just hacking in there and if I do
see you'll show you which one it is
and now to delete it all I do is see dot
Tooley again I'm copy pasting copying
and pasting for time purposes saving
time but for your self like take the
time to actually write all of this out
okay this is very very helpful for you
so now that I deleted it showed me that
it's deleted and if we actually check
again right it'll only show
these two choices right here okay now
we're gonna get into a pretty exciting
part which is introducing the Django
admin and we're actually gonna just
touch on it a little bit and let's get
started this is a super cool part
philosophy for generating admin sites
for your staff or clients to add change
and delete content is tedious work that
doesn't require much creativity okay
it's usually like a pretty
rinse and repeat process it's
frustrating it's boring you can make
mistakes it takes a lot of time and
development and which means like ill
cost your client a lot and it slows down
your development speed for that reason
Django entirely automates creation of
admin interfaces for models okay
so let's check it out the admin isn't
intended intended to be used by site
visitors it's for site managers okay so
now we're gonna create an admin user I'm
gonna do Python manage that py create so
we're gonna exit out of this I'm gonna
do Python and use that py create super
user and I'll leave this blank I'll use
this email
and even though it's not gonna show you
anything here it's still typing in your
password so don't worry about that okay
so you can put in whatever as your email
whatever as your username and now the
final step is to answer your entry or
password I have and now lets us start
the development server so we're gonna do
just that I'm gonna start the
development server
we're gonna go to Chrome we're gonna go
to our local app on 127 0.01 colon 8000
part instead of polls I'm actually gonna
go to admin and when I go to admin look
it brought up this nice interface that
you and I did not make we didn't make
this beautiful looking form where when
you hover over login it like turns dark
and looks good and we didn't add
functionality that adds security right
we didn't add this thing where passwords
automatically looks like dots so nobody
can see it all of this keep in mind is
just automatically generated when I
click login boom here's the
administrator interface okay so as the
admin you can change your password you
can log out you can check who are the
users so here's one user you can like go
into this user and like delete this user
or change the permissions of this user
right so you can go and you'd be like
boom it's not a super user anymore or
it's not a staff anymore it's not active
anymore or you can go in here and like
change all kinds of permissions like can
delete choice can add a question but
cannot like delete a question can change
a session but cannot delete a content
type you know you can get like as
specific with it as you want and this is
just for the model that we have
registered users but imagine later when
if we register our choice model and
whatever those will all show up right
over here and any in recent actions that
you do actually show up on the right
hand side so imagine like somebody
deleted something you're like
the hell happen like one part of our app
or this website is now broken well if
you go into recent actions you'll see
what took place and exactly who did it
and who'd hold responsible for that I
think that's pretty cool right and it
comes built-in right out of the gate
that's one of the reasons why Django is
such a powerful tool and it fosters
productivity and effectiveness I believe
over any other framework right and that
their tagline which is awesome its
Django is for perfectionist with
deadlines and that's what I believe in -
like if I have to put a project together
and I'm doing something so low I'm going
Django
all day baby but you know if you're
working on some long-term project you
know you're gonna be doing for a long
time and nothing else really matters
then yeah you can choose whatever you
want but I like speed I like
productivity I like to take my ideas
from my head and launch them online fast
alright with that said let's go back and
see what they're saying so we go to our
admin enter the admin site and now it
says make the pull app modifiable in the
admin how do we do that we're gonna take
these three lines of code so I'm gonna
go into my pull slash admin and this
line is already added so I'm not gonna
add it in from dot models import
question okay so basically what I'm
saying is from this directory get the
models so right here and import the
class question from the models okay so I
import the question model and then I'm
gonna say register that model inside of
admin so check out what happens okay
this is super super cool check it out
I'm gonna hit save and let's go back to
our app and let's hit refresh and look
at that it's here so that questions
model is the one we made it shows under
polls questions and you can see all of
those questions what's poppin what
you you can go in and you can change the
text I can change it to like what's
cracking right I can hit save and now
it's changed and if I go to my if I
start Python manage that py shell from
polls dot models import question
question dot objects all right look it
says what's cracking so what we actually
change from the GUI interface with our
mouse and our keyboard is now showing up
in our database in our local database
the sequel Lite database actually being
stored on our computer this database is
not online yet so pretty freakin cool
right how quickly and how effectively it
works so I'm gonna exit out of this I'm
gonna run my server again and we're
gonna go back to the app refresh cool
and like let's see what they're saying
now that we have registered question
Jango knows that it should be displayed
on the admin index page and it is right
and I showed it to you and we went
inside of it and we saw question text
and we saw a date published and we can
actually change the date published and
everything now things to note here the
form is automatically generated from the
question model so this form is
automatically generated we didn't eat
generate anything the different model
fuel types daytime filled and car filled
so remember we had one of the models as
a date/time field and the other one is
car filled and you can see where it says
date published look date field right and
for question text is just a straight-up
character field or what you know in
Python to be as a string these
correspond to the appropriate HTML input
widget each type of field knows how to
display itself in the Django admin
pretty cool
each date/time field gets free Java
Script shortcuts woohoo free Java Script
shortcuts that's awesome - normally
you'd have to write
javascript for all this stuff but like
look at this okay so let's say I go to
what's cracking and I click here boom
look at this beautiful day time picker
thing opens up and you could pick today
or you could pick another date and
they'll like automatically pick it and
you could pick the time and that's cool
this is this is something you'd have to
write a lot of manual JavaScript for
that's automatically written for you
dates get a today shortcut and calendar
pop-up and times get a now shortcut and
convenient pop-up that lists commonly
entered times the bottom part of the
page gives you a couple of options right
so save saves changes and return so the
change list page for this type of object
so you can do save or you can do save
and continue editing so continue editing
the same page or you can do save and add
another so add a new question and go
write or you can do delete which
displays a delete confirmation page to
check this out okay normally when you
hit you have to add all this
functionality plus when you hit delete
you have to then remember to add a
confirmation thing to it and they have
it automatically so if I had delete
it'll be like are you sure you want to
delete the question what's cracking all
of the following or related items will
be deleted questions one so only one
question and objects what's cracking you
can say yes I'm sure
or no take me back now notice it's
showing the question as what's cracking
that's because of your string method
that you added your STR method if you
did not have that it would not show like
what's cracking it was show like
question one and you would just have to
use your memory to remember that I'm
gonna say no take me back and it'll take
me back okay cool
oh let's go back let's see what they're
saying here and then if the value of the
date publish doesn't match the time you
created it probably means you forgot to
set the time we can also set the current
time zone right so that's not a big deal
if I go in history here it says I
changed at three am it's not 3 a.m.
right now so that means like I need to
go inside of my settings and in my time
zone and change what my time zone is so
for example I think
there's like America / Los Angeles
something like that oh actually work
sweet for yourself just look up like
time zone
Django time zone settings and then find
yours and put that in for me I put this
in and it fixed my time instantly right
okay so yeah essentially that's it for
part 2
to jump into part 3 and we're gonna get
started so if you haven't already open
up Adam go to where you created your
mind site project right for me it was in
github my site I'm gonna click open and
I'm gonna say whatever open and recover
state cool and here it is and then if I
do command shift P and type in terminal
my terminal pops up bada BAM and also
make sure to do source activate my site
and we are good ok so writing your first
Django app part 3 so what they're
talking about here is they're saying ok
like look you have everything in Django
is essentially called a view okay so for
example if you have a blog homepage
that's a view if you have the ability to
comment like a comment action right
that's considered a view if you click on
a blog post and it shows you its details
we refer to that as a detail page but
that's still part of the view that's
essentially what they're saying right
over here another example of this is
like let's say I take you to Instagram
so let's say I click on clever Kazi
right this is essentially for Instagram
and let me just plug my Instagram here
to go follow me if you aren't already
because awesome and if you go here right
like look this is the home page for all
my posts ok this would be considered a
home page view if I click into it that's
considered a detail view because it's
only showing that one particular post ok
if I click here that's a comment action
which is you know you can work that into
the views so just wanted to show you
that so you understand where all of this
is coming from now we come over here and
that's now they're saying that in our
poll application we're essentially gonna
have index page in our views so this is
gonna display the latest few questions
we're going to have a detail page which
is gonna display a text with no results
but with a form to vote so when you
click
so like you come in you're a bunch of
questions you click on a question and
then boom it has like ability to vote it
up and down okay I assume and we have a
question results page so it's gonna
display the result for a particular
question how did that question do how
many votes it got and then we have vote
action so handles voting for a
particular choice in a particular
question okay cool
all right so now we kind of know that
we're gonna be creating like these
things okay
we're gonna be creating an index
homepage of detail and results and also
what they're staying over on this part
is it saying like hey man have you ever
seen really ugly URLs like this well
don't worry because in Django you can
make them really beautiful so you can
have them like this instead like John
Smith comm slash News Archive slash 2018
/ - or / February whatever and you can
make them look really nice how does it
work it works off of URL conf s-- or
your current URL configuration mapping
okay so you map URL patterns to views so
somebody goes to this URL it knows which
view to run alright so now we're gonna
write more views okay so we're gonna
write these guys here again I'm just
gonna copy it and talk about it for you
I encourage you to type it all out and
walk through it okay I'm just gonna
highlight the main part so I'm gonna go
in my poll slash views that py so in
polls I'm gonna go inside of views or
actually we're gonna leave the index for
now paste it here okay
so now we got detail we got results and
we got vote deed everything always takes
in a request object okay a request is
passed whenever you do anything I'm now
gonna touch on it too much right now but
this is a first parameter you kind of
always put in and then as your second
parameter we're putting in the specific
question ID this way we can look up that
particular question from the database so
let's say you wanted to look up a blog
post right so you have multiple blog
posts you want to be able to look up a
specific one well we're gonna use ID for
that and then
this case our ID is our primary key and
that will allow us to look up that
unique thing or in the instagrams case
it allowed us to look up that unique
post okay cool
now what we want to do is why are these
new views into the polls dot URLs module
by adding the following path calls ok so
that's what it's showing here I'm gonna
call I'm gonna copy this and I'm gonna
paste it into our poll slash URLs up he
why I'm going slash URLs and paste it
here alright so what does this mean if
you just go to slash polls right so John
Smith dot-com slash polls it's gonna run
this thing it's gonna match the empty
pattern after polls and then it's gonna
run the views dot index function okay if
you go to poll slash if you want to go
to something like poll slash 5 or
Instagram post slash whatever your post
is right if you want to be able to do
that you want a pattern that can match
that okay so if I put in 20 it shouldn't
break if I put in 8 it shouldn't break
it should always be matched and so how
we can do that is we basically do this
thing with angle brackets and do int
colon question underscore ID and this
can dynamically match whatever pattern
you put in another beautiful thing you
guys usually for URL mapping you have to
deal with ugly regular expressions
except for the latest Django you don't
have to worry about regular expressions
anymore so for example let's say you
wanted to match this particular pattern
well you can put this in and if somebody
puts in a 5 here right it'll
automatically know that it's an integer
and work if they put in something else
it might freak out okay so it's really
smart and then it says hey if somebody
goes to a URL like this automatically
takes them to the detailed view and if
somebody goes to a URL that ends in a
results like this then which is
essentially what you're saying here hey
any number followed by results take them
to the results 1 and any number followed
by the word vote take
to the vote view cool and let's see what
happened so I'm gonna run I'm gonna do
Python manage that py run server cool
and I will open up my Chrome and we will
go to this guy over here okay so now
we're getting an error is because we
actually have to go to that particular
URL so in this case let's go to slash
polls and it should run our index
function so I'm gonna do slash pulls
boom it ran our index function what does
our index function say let's go to our
views and that's what it says hello
world you have two polls index perfect
well what if somebody goes to poll slash
5 or poll slash 193 what happens then
it'll take us through the detail
function and what does the detail
function say it says you're looking at
question number what the question ID
cool so let's try and let's see what
happens I'm gonna do 193 okay so the
cool thing here that's happening is that
you're able to take what's in the URL
and you're able to pass it down to your
HTML so right here that 193 right if I
make it like some other crazy number
it'll pass that down here right so now
we're able to actually take in arguments
from our URL and use them in our code
what if I said something like this it'll
say hey that pattern actually is not
matched so that's exactly what we wanted
if you don't put in a number here it
should automatically detect it now if
you want to go to something like slash
poll slash a number slash results what
do you do okay so let's say I have this
number and I go to results just like
that and now it should say something
like you're looking at the results of
question followed by whatever it is okay
so you're looking at the results of
question right or a question to
and then if you go and try to do this
thing with vote you're gonna get the
same thing so if I go to my URLs it says
hey go to slash poll slash number slash
vote so we're gonna do slash poll slash
number or slash votes when I hit enter
and it says you're voting on question
two perfect that's exactly what we
should be getting here and it's looking
great
alright so it's saying hey like take a
look at this in your browser and it'll
display the placeholders and that's
exactly what it did and how does it work
well detail our function that we have
will take in a request object followed
by the question ID so when we pass in
the question I need to be 193 right this
part became 193 and this part is just
that request object so what they have
here again if you're confused about
objects and what the hell's going on
it's not completely necessary but you
should look at some object-oriented
programming stuff okay and I do have a
course on object-oriented programming
and you could comment on it if you're
interested
alright so the question ID is equal to
34 comes from this thing and I've
explained that to you already when you
put that in the URL this dynamically
actually pulls it out and once it
dynamically pulls it out because you see
it says here it says question ID
question ID that's where it's actually
pulling it from okay and that's
essentially it and then it says hey you
don't need to do ugly things like latest
HTML because it's not necessary and it's
apparently silly okay so don't do it
and you should write views that actually
do something and here they're saying hey
look issue is responsible for doing one
of two things either it should return
what it's supposed to return or give you
like a 404 and then the rest is up to
you so you know basically you can have a
view there it can read records from a
database so meaning reading records
reading posts from a database Instagram
posts Facebook posts
or it can generate PDF files or output
XML or create a zip file on the fly
anything you want and pretty much using
whatever Python libraries you want cuz
Django is 100% Python so you have full
Python power and then all Django wants
is that HTTP response okay so you can't
return it as a string you can't return
it
you have to return it to some kind of an
HTTP response or throw an exception okay
so now here's what they're doing they're
like alright we're gonna do something
cool what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take like all of the questions you have
we're gonna order it by the publication
date and then show the top five most
recent once okay how are they doing that
well I'm gonna copy this and then we're
gonna play around with it okay so we're
gonna go back to our thing and what do
they have here from that models import
questions and they're in our poll slash
views okay so this is one thing that we
need to do from dot models import
question because we don't have that so
we're gonna paste it in here and then
they want us to redefine our index okay
so we're gonna do just that I'm gonna
change my definition of what my index
function is alright so how is this
working
well question dot question that objects
are ordered by and what this thing does
is it'll take all your questions and
order it by something so in our models
if you look we have this thing
publication date so pub underscore date
so we're gonna order it by publication
date now what we're doing with this
minus sign is we're saying in the
reverse order okay so instead of the
oldest publication date and showing us
then the oldest way we wanted to show it
in a descending order so we wanted to
show us the recent ones first and then
what we're doing is that we're just and
so this will return to us a list okay
and then you can index a list in Python
by doing this and we're just saying give
us the first five so from 0 up to but
not including five so zero one two
three four that's five okay and then as
output we're saying hey join all of them
all of the questions by a comma okay so
if you want to know a little bit more
about like how the Python is working in
there so here we're doing a list
comprehension and you can read more
about list comprehensions if you don't
know what that is it's not too important
and it's just a cool way of writing this
you know instead of multiple lines you
just write in one line and we're just
saying for each question
give us its text that's all we're saying
and then we're saying join it all by
commas so that's how it's gonna output
it so it's gonna return to us pretty
much a string okay and then we want to
return that okay as our output so we're
just gonna do HTTP response output
that's it so now let's take a look at it
so I'm gonna save it and we're gonna go
to our thing and we'll try to go to our
index and where's our index it's just
that slash pulls okay that should
trigger our index and let's see what
happens so I hit enter and it shows me
all my questions if you remember I
created three questions what's cracking
what's new what's up and is showing us
would separated by a comma ha I could do
show it to us separated by three stars
if i refresh it separated by three stars
you could separate it by an image
whatever you want you know this is just
pure Python okay that's essentially it
but there's something wrong here and the
thing that's actually wrong here is like
look you're not gonna have your toilet
and your refrigerator in the same room
right your muddying the water just like
that you don't want to have your HTML
code and your Python in the same place
we want to kind of separate it out so
right now the design of our page is in
the same place that handles our logic
okay so what we want to do is handle our
logic by pure Python in one place and
all our HTML and the design of the page
should be outside of this
logic okay so we want to create
something for that so what we're gonna
do and what this tutorial tells us to do
is inside polls you want to create a new
folder and you want to call this folder
templates this is important the case
sensitivity of this is important as well
as the name so if you mess up the name
when you put a typo you're gonna kind of
get messed up here also pay attention to
the order of Aldus okay so under my site
so under polls you're gonna have
templates and then inside of templates
you want to create a new folder and you
want to call it polls all right and
inside of this is where you're gonna
throw all your HTML files so we're gonna
create we're gonna create a new file in
here and we're gonna call it index.html
okay so just in slow motion for you
polls templates polls index okay so
essentially it's like polls templates
polls index like that alright let's go
back to our tutorial and that's what
it's saying it's saying that hey django
will automatically look for it and find
these templates and essentially to
django the path will look like poll
slash index at HTML because of how
django works and looks for these and you
can override it and do all kinds of
advanced stuff you know if you want to
read more into that we're gonna just
kind of keep it a little bit basic so
everybody can follow all right and now
we're gonna put the following code into
into that template so it's telling us
which file to put that code and so i'm
just gonna hit this button copy this
code and we're gonna go into our
index.html and i will paste it right
over here okay what is this code saying
it's saying hey if there are any
questions then i want you to create an
unordered list okay that's what a ul tag
is in HTML and then what I want you to
say is for a question and so for any
questions I want you to
like a bullet point and show that
question okay and link to that
particular question otherwise say that
there are no polls available so if we
didn't have any questions at all it'll
say no polls available and then end the
if statement okay so we're starting our
for loop here we're ending it here we
start our if statement here and then we
have our else statement here and we have
our end if here all right so that's cool
now we want to make sure that we
actually link to this index.html file
how are we gonna do that here's how
now let's update our index view in pulse
slash views that py to use the template
okay so we're gonna do just that and
also let's update our index function
just a little bit so here's a few lines
that we're adding let's go back to our
views and we will so the latest question
will keep that and we'll just paste this
in here alright save so what's going on
we're still getting those most recent
five questions but that's what latest
question list is gonna become and if you
don't have five questions they'll pick
the top three or top or the recent most
four okay something like that
and then what we're doing is we're
loading that template poll slash index
at HTML
okay so we're using loader and then
there's something called context
dictionary in Django and what you can do
is you can pass from the back end server
side pass this to your front end your
HTML code it'll know about it okay so if
I go back to our templates my index.html
how is it getting access to this
variable latest question list well we're
actually passing it in our context
alright that's that's what's going on
and then we're saying as HTTP response
template dot render we're saying hey
send that context with that request and
send it over to the HTML file so it
sends all that over to the
Team Alpha and then our HTML file has
access to that latest question okay and
this weird stuff you're seeing here with
this with a % squiggly bracket that's
Django template in engine okay so it's
basically HTML with the little Django
pass odds cool and so now they're like
hey this is such a common step to load a
template and then to do template dot
render that there they made a shortcut
for it which is just render so how can
you use that like this okay so basically
you can remove this line you don't need
this line anymore and thanks to this
line at the top from Django dot
shortcuts import render which you should
have we're gonna use this render and how
are we gonna do it we can just replace
all of this and we can say render the
first argument is request okay and then
after that the path to that index file
so poles slash index dot HTML just like
that followed by the context dictionary
so in this case we're just calling it
context okay sometimes what I like to
call this is stuff for front-end alright
just to keep it consistent and just so
you know the thing that you're accessing
on the back end is not this guy it's the
dictionary context dictionary key so
it's actually this string alright and
that's will give you back this guy okay
so note that once you have done all this
in views we no longer need to import
loader blah blah blah exactly that's
what we did and now they're gonna show
us how to raise a 404 error alright so
what happens if it doesn't exist so
let's tackle the question detail view
the page that displays the question text
for a given poll here's the view so in
poll slash use a py what we're gonna do
is we're gonna from Django HTTP import
HTTP 404 so since we're already using
Django dot HTTP to import
should be response we're also gonna say
HTTP 404 okay just like that we're gonna
save it and then we're gonna come back
and now it wants us to make changes to
our detailed view and it's saying hey
turn it into this so let's turn it into
that and I'm gonna save it so try except
blocks all it does is if there's an
error try except blocks we'll catch it
okay try except block it is pretty much
the same thing as if then condition
except that if you're running into some
kind of crazy error try except blocks
will catch it and still run for example
if you divided a number by zero and
Python your code will just freakin crash
right I'll give you this red blob your
app will crash whatever you're doing but
if you run a try except block that says
if you get a zero division error then
just pass you'll not get that error I'll
just pass it okay so what we're saying
is we're saying try to get that
particular that one specific question
okay so we're saying we're getting that
question ID and we're saying get that
object that has that primary key or that
question ID or where that primary key is
equal to the question ID so if I pass in
a URL like app comm slash polls slash
six right what is gonna do or let's say
/ - what it'll do is pass this two in to
here that this will become - and the
question will get the question object
that has an ID of two in this case it
might be one of my question that I think
is what's new right now what's new
question so then this question will
become the what's new question object
and then what we do is that we just
return that okay and we pass it in our
context dictionary and we pass that
question in here except if the question
does not exist then we raise HTTP four
and we say a question does not exist
okay cool let me make sure to delete
that that's not supposed to be there I
just added that to show you guys what's
up
okay the new concept here the view
raises yep we'll discuss what you could
put in that poll slash detail that HTML
template a bit later but if you'd like
to quickly get the above example working
a file containing just this okay so
we're gonna get that thing working okay
so in here we're gonna create a new file
and we're gonna call it a detail dot
HTML and in detail we're just gonna put
questions just like that okay so now we
got to make it work and we're gonna go
and get our question to okay so because
that specific question exists look it
says what's new now if I change this ID
to one is gonna get the question that
was what's up if I change it to three
it's gonna be the what's cracking but
what happens if I change it to four
remember I only created three questions
if I change it to four it says page not
found and look the error it throws up is
question does not exist now if we didn't
have that right if we actually don't
have that so let's go back to our views
and I'll just remove this and I'll just
say instead of raised I'll just say pass
okay pass is equivalent of saying ignore
to Python let's go back let's refresh
we're gonna get this ugly error which we
don't actually know what to do with or
what it means and it is very confusing
but when we have this when we raise this
thing and I refresh you see it says
question does not exist so it's a lot
easier for us to see what the problem is
is because we know it's coming from here
then we can like start debugging and
know what's going on okay so that's why
that particular thing is important all
right let's move on along all right so a
shortcut so instead of having this try
accepting on rays we can actually do a
cute shortcut that says get object or
404 and that's a method that's in Python
in Django it comes with it so we'll
throw that and it's in our short
so from Django da shortcuts import
render and actually import get object or
404 okay and just to stay consistent
with them will do it and is because
starts with the G and starts with R so
alphabetical orders and pep eight and
okay alright so we're gonna go here we
will go to where it says question in
detail and we're gonna remove this whole
thing okay
make our life easier and all we're gonna
do is we're gonna say but BAM right
we're gonna say hey get object or 404 so
that particular question with the
primary key of this if it doesn't exist
then it'll automatically say it doesn't
exist and then pretty much the last line
will keep it what it was
we'll save this and basically as our
context dictionary we're saying passed a
question as a question okay so there are
three arguments in here request the HTM
passes HTML file as a string and then a
dictionary so then we can use it on our
back-end again in our detail HTML we can
actually use we can see that question
save and now let's try to go to it again
so I'll say for and now look it says no
question matches the given query
question as in like no question object
okay but if I do three it finds it and
takes us to it so this is what we mean
this is what I mean when I say Python is
really a Django is really awesome it
comes with a lot of intelligent defaults
whereas you don't have to write allotted
a lot of this code right it works on
that dry principle do not repeat
yourself and a lot of these things just
come built-in out-of-the-box and it it
speeds up your development time saves
you a lot of those new code lines
because every new code line that you're
right there's an additional chance for
an error so the amount of code lines
that you can reduce less errors you will
make plus your code just looks beautiful
and so much more readable right get
object or
for instead of try deaded it up accept
object does not exist right so it's
confusing okay let's go on get object or
404 this is some advanced stuff we're
gonna skip that for now now that says
use the template system so in our
detailed HTML we're gonna go and I'm
gonna paste that there save it and let's
see what it's saying back to the detail
view for our pol application here's what
it should look like okay so now let's go
to the detail and let's see first let's
just see what the result is right and
then we'll talk about it I'll hit enter
what's cracking is showing it to me in a
nicer way let's do two it's showing it
to me in a nicer way what happens if I
do four same thing no question matches
the given query okay so what are they
doing here did take your particular
question and they wrap it up in h1 tag
in HTML anything that's an h1 tag will
make its called a heading 1 and you can
go all the way down to heading 6 heading
6 being the smallest heading 1 being the
biggest boldest so we have an in a
heading 1 and then right underneath it
we say 4 choice in question that choice
underscore set at all so for all of the
choices as like at choices as in the
particular answers you can have to each
question right though those answers are
the ones that actually get an upload or
there's no down low so an upload show me
all of those answers except in this case
we don't have any answers or any choices
so that's why it's not showing those how
is it working the template system uses
dot lookup syntax so you'll do question
doc question text so go into the
question and then it'll access the
question underscore text another thing
to notice if you're more advanced if the
question underscore text attribute did
not exist it would go and try to access
it as a list index okay so imagine if it
was like if you did question dot 0 or
something like that so you you're still
using dot notation
so that's something that could trip you
up later okay
it would have tried a list index lookup
okay and then method calling happens in
the for loop so this for loop method
calling is happening there because you
know you're doing question that choice
underscore set dot all okay and then
it's interpret as Python code which is
cool like right here and it returns an
iterable of choice objects and then we
iterate over it right so that's why we
use a for loop and then we iterate over
it now remember when we wrote the link
to a question the pole slash index dot
HTML so let's go to our pole slash index
dot HTML you can see what we did here
right so we said slash so for the links
we said slash poles slash this right so
let's go take a look at this page one
more time we're gonna go right here and
I'm just gonna hit holes and hit enter
so you can see how it's showing me
what's cracking what's new what's up so
each of this and when you click into it
you go into its detailed view right kind
of like when you click into a blog post
and also under what's up you can
actually see the choices so that's just
a recent thing we just added right so
how is that working how are we linking
it and how we're linking and we're
saying slash poles slash that question
ID which matches one of the paths in our
URLs that py so if I take you to my URL
it'll match the path of this guy and
that takes you to the detailed view and
that's how we can see the detailed view
so let's go back but we're hardwiring
the URL paths this way if we have a lot
of URL paths our logic can get messed up
or if we change if we go in our URLs
that py and I
I don't know change this path to be
something else right it has like it says
polls here again followed by something
else it could like mess us up so what we
want to do is we want to use it in a
so that's what they're showing us here
so they're saying hey replace this guy
with this guy so we're gonna do just
that okay so we're gonna go back to our
index.html and we will just do this okay
so now what this is saying is for the
URL use detail detail as in this that's
where we're getting the name from and
then as the argument pass in the
question dot ID so this question since
we're looping over it if you do question
dot use the dot notation it'll get you
that particular questions ID so question
that ID that's what you pass in as the
argument and so then when you go to your
URLs to this question ID that's what
it's gonna pass okay that's essentially
it and I believe you should also be able
to do question underscore ID equals that
but in this case we're just gonna keep
it like this okay so no need for keyword
arguments okay and then in in between
here so that's what it's gonna link to
it's gonna link to the detailed view of
that particular question and the text
that we're generating is just from right
here so that's question and dot question
underscore text if you are confused by
this look up stuff on HTML okay and look
up how links work in HTML again I'm not
gonna go into too much HTML cuz that's
outside the scope of this tutorial
okay okay and that's how it's
essentially working now namespacing URL
names it's basically just telling us
like hey look so let's go down over here
let's just make sure we're not missing
anything okay from the top
okay so they're saying if you want to
change the URL to something else perhaps
it's something like pole slash specific
slash 12 so this is something that I've
already said but but they're just
reiterating here and they're saying it
like if you change the URL it's still
gonna work now that we change it to be
the dynamic way okay
so now we can change our URL pattern to
whatever and it's not hardwired anymore
and now they're talking about name
spacing URL names okay
so this way you want to make sure that
all of your apps actually have there's
no way for like right now we only have
two poles app right but what if we
wanted to have more apps inside of this
then what could happen is that if any of
our HTML files name matched so let's say
you have a poles app and it has an
index.html file right what if you had a
blog app and that also had an index.html
file now you're gonna have a collision
so what we do for that that's us that's
the reason why we create under templates
another folder called poles and if we
want it to add templates for a blogging
app that's why we would have an app
called blog and then under that we'd
have templates and then under that we'd
have blog and then under that would put
our HTML stuff okay that's the reason
why we do it like that and this way
there is going to be no collisions okay
now change your poll slash index dot
HTML so let's see what it's saying here
so we can have our app name app
underscore named Abner our name is equal
to polls so this is in our URLs a py so
let's go right there
URLs not py and they're saying hey add
that guy right over here okay and pretty
much everything else we want to just
leave as is now change your poll slash
index dot HTML template from this to
this
so in our index.html we're gonna go
right here and we're gonna paste that
guy so notice the difference all we did
is we do polls equals D P polls colon
detail okay that's really the only
difference there's no other difference
I'm gonna save that and this way our
URLs will never collide and everything
has a proper name spacing right because
right now we created a detail for our
polls what if you want to create a in
what if you had to add a new app called
blog and then create details in there
you don't want it to just be called
detail because it's gonna collide with
the polls detail but now because it's
polls : detail then later you can do
blog : detail or Instagram post : detail
or Facebook status : detail and this way
you can differentiate all of those
different apps you have within one of
your Django projects okay
writing your first django app part 4 all
right so we're continuing a web poll
application and it will focus on simple
processing simple form processing and
cutting down our code so the big things
we're gonna be doing is how do you add a
form that where you can submit
information to so basically it's gonna
be a form it's gonna have radio buttons
you're gonna pick your choice you're
gonna click on it and then you're gonna
be able to send that data over that's
number one big thing we're gonna be
doing the second big thing we're gonna
be doing is cutting down our code using
something called Django's generic views
they are super super powerful and it
makes your code a lot more readable and
it stops you from doing the same thing
over and over again ok so it makes
things a lot simpler for you it does
have a little bit of magic involved but
hey that's what I'm here for and I'm
gonna break it down so let's jump right
into it all right so writing a simple
form I'm gonna cop this guy and then I'm
gonna break it down to you you my friend
should not be copying you're learning
this stuff you should be writing this
down line by line and going hmm how does
this work ah that's how it works
Oh huh and then you should be googling
it and looking it up okay for me I know
how this works
I don't want to waste my time gonna copy
paste it and then break it down for you
capisce let's get going all right so
let's pop open our atom and we will go
into our detailed HTML and we're gonna
put this over that okay so what is going
on at a higher level we have a four-hour
heading one so this is where what the
specific question is okay so what's up
what's cracking what's popping things
like that all right here this line is
saying hey man look if there are any
error messages I just want you to
freaking show them that's all and this
guy over here is just a form where you
actually submit and vote okay at a high
level that's all that's happening okay
now
getting down more into the code level
this is pretty self-explanatory is just
age one taxes just HTML here is a little
bit of Django going on so here we're
saying if there are there is an error
message then show it okay and show it
covered in strong tax so it looks nice
and then here's where we're creating a
form so we start the form tag here and
end the form tag here the action is to
go to this specific URL so trigger this
URL so basically action means what the
heck happens when you submit a form
right what's an example of a form you
every almost every website has it okay
so you going on Instagram and logging in
you are submitting a form you logging in
on YouTube you logging in on Facebook
you are submitting a form you posting a
status hitting post you are submitting a
form okay so that's essentially what's
going on so well we can say here for
action once you submit a form what
should happen okay one thing you could
do here is just type in facebook.com so
once you submit this form it just takes
you to facebook.com okay you can
certainly do that except in our
application what you want to do is once
somebody submits a form you want to send
them over to some other part of your app
with that information with that data for
example if somebody adds shoes to their
cart it then takes them to the new page
with the information where they're
previously added shoes to their cart and
it shows the shoes and the shirt and the
tie on the Pursey to checkout page ok
that's essentially how you use forms in
real life okay so here we have it - hey
take me to the vote view okay or the
vote function in our views file cool
CSRF token so there's something called
cross-site I forget what it fully stands
for let's take a look at it they mention
it cross-site request forgery is okay so
it's a security mechanism and all you
have to do is
don't worry about it too much all you
have to do is just add that token okay
so actually that's it that token doesn't
even need an end that's it this is just
a line that you add usually when you're
adding Django forms unless you're using
something like crispy forms which is
again outside the scope of this tutorial
so that's what this line is here we're
doing a simple for loop
okay the for loop goes through all the
question choices and what our question
choice is well remember each so you have
question and then one question can have
multiple answers to it those answers are
the things that yet I've voted on so
what we're doing now is listing out all
of those answers or those or those
choices and and and and I'll show you
right now how it'll actually look okay
so let's go ahead and check out what
this looks like so now we're gonna go
over to our app and let's say I click on
what's cracking and you can see it says
what's cracking followed by vote right
underneath it okay let's go to what's up
what's up has two choices remember I had
not much and the sky those are two
possible answers kind of funny I don't
know which one I like more but yeah you
could you could vote on one and then you
could certainly hit vote okay yours is
not gonna look as big as mine that's
because I have it zoomed in so you could
see on my 5k iMac Retina screen and you
can pick whichever one you want that's
it and then you hit vote boom okay
you're voting on question one it
redirect you to that cool so that was
that the radio buttons are coming from
these lines okay how's this working
input type radio' when you do this then
it creates those radio buttons on the
side okay I for ID something you don't
have to worry about too much but for ID
we're just using the built-in Django
template in systems for loop counter so
I'll give the ID one two three four as
its looping through and yeah value is
just a choice that ID and name we're
just calling a choice name is very
important
once you get this on the server side the
back end you could reference this post
data using that particular name okay so
you're gonna be able to do something
like a request I post bracket choice
okay and then label four that's just for
labeling purposes again not incredibly
important to what we're doing and then
we end the loop right over here and then
right over here we're saying this form
is basically what we're saying is like
put that submit button and then just
call it vote okay so that's why you see
you know if I called it something else
and saved it and refresh now it calls
with that so here we're saying call it
vote and then for type we're gonna say
it's a submit button so the type we're
just gonna give a submit so once you hit
it it sends that information over to the
next page cool let's go back to our
tutorial alright so that's pretty much
what is gonna explain to us but let's
just see and make sure we're not missing
anything right so the value of each
radio button is associated is associated
question choices ID the name of each
radio button is choice yep that means
when somebody selects one of the radio
buttons and submit the form will send
the post data choice where a number is
the ID of the selected choice this is
the basic component of HTML forms okay
we said the forms action to that
particular URL and we said method is
equal to post so here's another
important thing to note this is pretty
important whenever you're generally
submitting data or filling out a form
and sending it over you want to use post
requests because it's safer and it's
better you don't want to be using get
requests when you're sending data over
because it's insecure and you could get
screwed okay
so simply put as opposed to yet it's
very important because the act of
submitting this form will alter data
server-side whenever you create a form
that all
data server-side use method post this
tip isn't specifically Django is just
good web development practice for loop
dot counter indicates how many times the
four tag has gone through its loops okay
I've explained this already since we're
creating a post form we need to worry
about cross-site request forgeries and
I've already gone over this as well okay
and that's why we're using CSRF token
all right now let's create a Django view
that handles and submitted data and does
something with it or remember in
tutorial 3 we create a URL con for the
that includes this line so we already
have this line we don't have to add it
so if I go to my URL stop py you'll see
four votes I have this line right over
here and so should you all right now
let's add the now that we're gonna
create a real version for our vote so up
until now we had a functionality for a
vote but it was just dummy placeholder
didn't really do anything okay so now
we're gonna actually add real
functionality what are the few things we
need that we don't have let's see we
will need HTTP response redirects
because we don't have that so we're
gonna put that in alright we're gonna
save what else do we need we need from
Django dot URLs import reverse so we're
gonna add that in and hit save and then
that's essentially essentially and then
it except we're gonna have a choice
right here safe cool okay now we're
gonna go in our vote and we need to add
all of this code okay and I'll break it
down for you right about now okay so
what's going on here question we get
that particular question or we throw a
404 error we then get the answers for
that particular question okay or select
a choice one specific choice that's what
we get okay so for example whether the
choice is going to be the sky or whether
the true
is gonna be something else right it's
not gonna show it to me right now
because the app is offline right now the
server is closed but since we had two
choices and you could vote for this
choice or this choice how are you gonna
know which one is sent right so that's
what we're trying to pick here which
ever choice you select the radio button
next to that's whose primary key we're
gonna be passing in and how we get that
is request that post choice request that
post is just a dictionary and you could
index you could get pull out the key
choice from that okay just to have it
make sense let's see let's run this code
so what is it saying the problem is
right here all right we're gonna run
this code cannot import name reverse
HTTP 404 let's see where that error is
coming from AHA right there reverse okay
and you could still have HTTP 404 not a
problem all right
so let's go back to our app let's go to
what's up and also let's go back to this
save it come back let's refresh I should
say vote here now when I hit the sky
we're gonna see what happens so I'm
gonna hit inspect here and our console
pops up right we're gonna go to sources
console is looking pretty insane right
now but that's fine I'm gonna click on
network and we're gonna click vote so
we're just voted for this guy okay now
in our network let's see if we can zoom
out a little bit because it's a little
too crazy alright so in our network we
can see that the requests Methodist Post
right and we can actually check out the
response and in this case it says the
response failed let's click here right
now when I click results because it was
sent to
results it says you're looking at the
results of question one right so there
is a response and now if I look in the
headers it tells me the request method
right now is get and it tells me kind of
all the things that go along with it
right so let's try it out again let's
pick another question not much and vote
let's see what happens
so 3:02 found right okay
so let's go here preview response failed
to load response data if I go in results
it's showing me you're looking at the
results of question number one okay so
pretty much it says the same thing and
it's giving my statuses what do these
mean we're gonna break it down a little
bit later okay so let's go back to our
tutorial and go down index.html okay so
this is looking good our views it's
looking fine cool now so yeah so
basically we're selecting the specific
choice from here whatever we get we send
over in our request and then we throw an
accept choice that we throw an exception
here okay
and we also check for if like the choice
does not exist or if there's an Kier and
in the case that the choice does not
exist we return polls slash detailed
HTML we render that and we return that
question object and for our error
message we say that you didn't select a
choice okay so if you somehow it
selected you know nothing and otherwise
if we have selected it and we haven't
ran into this issue what we want to say
is for that particular choice we want to
upload it by one so we're incrementing
the vote count by one we want to save it
and then we redirect okay so we're gonna
go into more depth of that but let's
just check this part out one more time
refresh
let's said inspect let's go to network
let's select the sky let's click vote so
you can see okay so that's that's
exactly what I needed here it's a little
hard to see though so you can see when I
scroll all the way down that it actually
pulls out the form data and it's telling
me that the choice I selected was the
second choice right that's the important
part and it also has a CSRF middleware
token which remember we did CSRF
underscore token that's where it's
generating that from but the choice is
the most important one so whether it was
choice one or is choice two and we're
picking this based on the choice ID okay
so that's essentially what's happening
now if I go back and I pick not much and
I vote and when I go back up to vote and
I go all the way down you'll see that
it's showing me choice one right so
that's the thing that we're actually
pulling out so this will essentially
turn to a one or a two that's what I was
trying to get at earlier but it was just
my screws too big so it was hard for me
to show it but that's what gets selected
here and once this a value to something
like a 1 or something like a 2 this
whole thing evaluates to that specific
question object and then we upload it
and then we save it and then we redirect
ok the reason why you so when you're
done with all of this you don't want to
say hey go back to the home page or you
don't want to just say like a render the
home page because if the user refreshes
it'll keep submitting that data over and
over again so like imagine right if you
were about to pay for your credit card
and you buy like whatever right you buy
shoes or you buy grocery if you refresh
like something happens during half of it
then it gets submitted but then you go
back and you refresh or you resubmit it
shouldn't let you resubmit and pay
again right every time you refresh and
then all of a sudden you're charged like
$300 or what if you were on an online
trading app and you just put down like
$3,000 for Bitcoin and then you refresh
or you go back and forward a page and it
resubmits three thousand and three
thousand dollars again you're gonna run
out of money pretty fast right nine
thousand dollars like that so it's a
pretty serious issue so what you want to
do instead is redirect this prevents
data from being posted twice if a user
hits the back button okay there's a
better way to do redirect which I think
they'll show us later but it's
essentially I think from shortcuts you
can pull out redirect and just call
redirect and it's much simpler but they
do it this way she be response redirect
reverse and then take me to the results
view right so it takes you back to this
results view and for argument it just
passes in the question ID cool so that's
looking good now let's play around with
it and let's just check out what happens
so I've already voted for like one or
two questions multiple times let's see
what's going on on our database I'm
gonna go in Python manage that py shell
so we're gonna do is from polls that
models I'm gonna import choice and I'm
also gonna do from polls dot models
import question question dot objects
dot get let's say we want to get our
first question or whatsup question and
we're gonna save this question as like
queue or something and now what I'll do
is I'll do queue that choice underscore
set that all now will show me all the
choices or answers for it and then I'll
pull out the the sky one and then for
the sky one we can see it's vote count
in models I forget what is the vote or
is it votes so you can see that it has
two votes and then
other one Arizona also has two votes so
it's a tie okay so both have two votes
so you see that what we're doing on our
front end and we're voting it's actually
being counted here okay usually where it
says choice underscore set that's kind
of weird so how you want to say it is
like Q dot choice says and again like
I've mentioned in our four at the end of
our first video like if you want to
change that I'm not gonna change it now
just to stay consistent with Django's
official Docs but essentially like right
in here right right on the top we can
actually write something called related
underscore name and then fix this issue
like right there call it something like
related underscore name and give it
Joyce says okay something like that but
we're not gonna do it right now we're
gonna stick to a Django is doing because
otherwise I'll have to make migrations
and things like that everything is fine
for now I'm gonna exit out of this and I
will just do Python manage that py run
server and just go back to using our
regular app cool all right so now let's
see what they want us to do so that's
all good that's working all right let's
see what they're saying here request
that post is a dictionary like object
lets you access submitted data by key
name yep so that's how we we use a
choice key name request that post values
are always strings cool
note that Django also provides requests
I get that's by default that's there but
we're explicitly using requests that
post and our code to ensure that data is
only altered via post call it will raise
a cure if choice wasn't provided and
post data the above code checks for key
error right over here andrey displays
the question form with an error message
if choice isn't given after incrementing
the choice count the code returns an
HTTP response redirect rather than it
normal
redirect this redirect takes a single
argument the URL to which the user will
be redirected see the following point
for how we construct the URL in this
case and you should always return an
HTTP response redirect after
successfully dealing with post ok we're
using reverse function constructor this
function helps avoid having to hard code
a URL in the View function it is given
the name of the view that we want to
pass control to and the variable portion
of the URL pattern that points to that
view cool so right here now after
somebody votes in a question the vote
view redirects to the results page for
the question let's write that view so
now it should point us back to the
results and we're gonna write it ok so
here is what it should be looking like
let's check our results just pop that
bad boy whoops pop that boy right in
here and we just say get that particular
question or other Westerwelle 404 and
once you get it
take me to and once you get that
question take me to Roselle's dot HTML
so you can already see there's some
similarities right like here there's a
similarity and here there's a similarity
both of these have to do with getting
that one particular question so think of
it like you're getting the result
detailed view for both of them but in
one you're sending me to detail that
HTML on the other one you're selling
sending me two results at HTML ok
and we're gonna kind of address this
issue of like our code being a little
bit repeated this is almost exactly the
same as a detailed view from tutorial 3
the only difference is a template name
will fix this redundancy later
so they mentioned that now let's create
a poll / results dot HTML so we're gonna
go in and create new file I'm gonna call
it resolves dot HTML just like that I'll
paste it here
and we'll go to our app and will vote
for the sky and then it'll take us to
the results of what's up and look at
that not much it says two votes on the
sky three votes vote again and then it
takes me back to the vote and I'll vote
for not much all right so it's coming
out pretty cool so far
all right is this is exciting guys this
is exciting so now what is this code
saying let's read our code that we've
just added header unordered list
unordered list the loop is saying go
through all of the choices or all of the
answers I don't know why they call it
choice I just think is a bad name and
get that choices choice text put two
dashes in between it so for example this
would turn this whole thing would turn
into like the sky or not much followed
by the number of votes followed by it's
saying vote choice out votes pluralized
right so what this is doing is it's
either gonna put an S here or not so for
example let's go here so if you only had
one vote it wouldn't this would turn
into nothing and if you had multiple
votes it would turn into it would put a
s here okay so it's a pretty cool way of
pluralizing something but you're doing
choice dot votes so this will evaluate
to like let's say three and then you're
piping it over to Plue
relize and then pluralize will be like
hey yes you should PluralEyes input an s
here and then i'll put like an ass like
that okay cool
would that said that ends a four loop so
you're doing not too much here and then
what you say is like hey you want to
vote again and how you how you're doing
that is you're just providing a link to
the tax vote again and it'll essentially
take you to the detailed view of that
particular question okay so if I hit
vote again it takes me to the detail
view of that question what's up not much
vote it takes me to the results view if
I hit vote again it takes me in a detail
view click it takes me to the results
view so this app is starting to have
some functionality again so again that's
pretty cool let's go here and let's
check out now go to poll slash one in
your browser and vote in the question we
did it gets updated each time you vote
if you submit the form without having
chosen a choice you should see the error
message okay so let's see if we can try
to do that let's hit vote and it says
you didn't select a choice perfect
that's exactly what we wanted note the
code for our vote view does have a small
problem it first gets the selected
choice object from the database then
computes the new value of votes and then
it saves it back to the database if two
users of your website try to vote at
exactly the same time this might go
wrong the same value let's say 42 will
be retrieved for votes then for both
users the new value of 43 is computed
and saved but 44 would be the next
expected value this is called a race
condition if you're interested you can
read avoiding race conditions using f to
learn how you can solve this issue okay
that's a little bit advanced it would
have to be literally at the same like
fraction of a second could it happen yes
if you're trying to scale your app to a
lot of users yes should you worry about
it right now
so let's continue all right so remember
what I mentioned in our view some of the
code is looking similar like here these
are detailed views right they're showing
the specific question and they need one
specific question looks a little
redundant right and then we're using
also a specific question like allowing
us to vote here but these there's a
little bit of redundancy going on so how
can we address this how can we manage
this in a better way well luckily for
you Jango has something called generic
views these are class-based views that
essentially have you once you use them
you don't have to write that much real
code it just does a lot of the things
Auto magically in a pretty intelligent
way so I like this and check it out
alright the detail and results views are
very simple as mentioned above but
they're redundant okay
the index view which displays a list of
polls is similar these views represent a
common case of basic web development
getting data from the database according
to a parameter passed in the URL loading
a template and returning the rendered
template so we pass stuff and we get it
from the URL and then we load up a
template and we return the render
template that's essentially what we have
been doing and when I said return the
render template another way to say it is
returning that HTML file you're looking
for right or that page on the front end
that you see because this is so common
Django provides a shortcut called
generic views system generic views
abstract common patterns to the point
where you don't even need to write
Python code to write an app you can
literally be sleeping and the app just
writes itself let's convert our poll app
to use the generic view system so we can
delete a bunch of our own code we'll
just have to take a few steps to make
the conversion we will one convert the
URL conf delete some of the old unneeded
views and introduce new views based on
generics generic django views all right
read on for detail
okay so why the coach shuffle what
they're basically saying is hey you
should know basic math before you start
using a calculator so why did we do this
up until this point only to now refactor
our code will we have to refactor our
code all the time no you will not
next time when you are doing your app
you already know how the class base use
work you'll start from more generic
class-based views so basically what
they're saying is like hey look we don't
want to just give you the calculator
before you even can do base like two
plus two or in my case in one of my
videos I think I had to do 2,000 divided
by 10 on a calculator that was a pretty
sad moment and that has a lot of upvotes
makes me sad to this day I wish my
editor took it out oh well you don't
always get what you want in life but
Jango generic views comes pretty close
so let's keep going
all right amend URL Conte first open the
poll /url sup py you're on conned then
change it like so so we're gonna go in
pull /url s dot py and I'm just gonna
paste it over this bad boy and explain
what the heck we just changed right so
besides the fact that we took out some
notes what else just changed so let me
let me take this out so you can kind of
see it side by side and really see what
changed so if you look at this index
thing all it changed
before it was just dot index now it's
index view dot as view detail view as
view results view dot as view and those
are the middle arguments that change
right what are the other arguments that
change everything after the name all the
name keyword arguments remained the same
but there was something else that
changed so here it says question
underscore ID everywhere but in the new
one it says peek hey everywhere if you
notice right so that's another big
change to keep in the back of your
forehead all right
that's what they mentioned over here
cool so that's essentially what we're
gonna be focusing on here so here we
still have question ID okay
now when we're using these generic views
they take things in as pk and they'll
explain that later and now we need to
make changes to our views we're going to
remove our old index detail and results
views and use Django's generic views
instead to do so open them and change it
like so so we definitely need this
generic thing so we're gonna do we're
gonna go to our views and here we're
gonna do from Django dot views import
generic alright so we got that other
things that we need now we need to make
a class here so I'm gonna completely
remove this guy and add a little class
here how will this work it'll
automatically know which template to use
based on this variable these variables
are not just random you can't just call
it this it will not work these variables
have to have this specific name for them
to work okay this is something important
for you to remember Django does have a
bit of magic but once you learn how it
works it'll be really really helpful
okay so template underscore name you
have to use this variable we assign it
to the index dot HTML for a context
object name we say latest question list
and for a query set we're just returning
the last 5 published published options
okay so this we're saying only be
referenced if somebody says this so when
somebody says this you can get me that
okay let's go in our class detail view
so for our detail all we need to write
is instead of doing this get object 404
passing the question passing the primary
key all that stuff and saying render
requests followed by the context
dictionary and all that
it's pretty simple how is it working
well it's actually pretty cool okay so
let's go back to our URLs and since
we're passing PK right in here it
already has it you don't even have to
pass it as an argument or anything which
model again these variable names matter
we're telling it use the question model
so it's directly communicating with this
model right over here template name we
just give it the template name and
that's it it knows what to do okay
pretty beautiful now let's do the same
thing for a results view so it's gonna
change from this obfuscated looking code
to something pretty simple check it out
clean right looks a lot cleaner no need
for requests and question ID no need for
a get object or 404 no need for passing
in question or primary key no need for
saying render request and passing in a
context dictionary it just does it all
automatically and then vote we're gonna
keep it the same okay we're gonna hit
save now we're using two generic views
here list view and detail view
respectively those two views abstract
the concept of display a list of objects
that's one concept so list view is gonna
do that and then the other concept is
display a detail page for a particular
type of object so are you looking at the
home page of Instagram or are you
clicking into one particular post and
looking at its detail a generic view
needs to know what model it will be
acting upon this is providing using the
model attribute which is this the detail
view generic view expects a primary key
value captured from the URL to be called
pk that's why here it has to be called
pk so we have changed question
underscore ID to PK for the generic
views
but not for the non-generic view by
default the detailed generic view uses a
template called app name / model name
underscore detailed HTML in our case it
would use the template the following
template right so if I go in my views
pull so app name our app name is pulls /
results that HTML so / / the model name
dot HTML okay in our case we just called
it results at HTML the template name
attribute is used to tell Django to use
a specific template name instead of the
auto-generated default template name we
also specify the template name for the
results list view this makes sure that
the results view in the detail view have
a different appearance when rendered
even though they're both a detail view
behind the scenes so they're both a
generic detail view okay
similarly the list view generic view
uses a default template called similar
to the other one we use template name to
tell ListView to use our existing one so
by using template name right over here
we're telling it which one to use
specifically in previous parts of the
tutorial the templates have been
provided with a context that contains
the question and latest question list
context variables for detail view the
question variable is provided
automatically so the question variable
is provided automatically instead of us
even having to pass it in as a context
dictionary because generic views are
smart since we're using a django model
our models called question django is
able to determine an appropriate name
for the context variable that's why it
would pull out question this would be
the variable name that you can use
automatically on your front-end in your
templates
however for ListView the automatically
generated context variables question
underscore list so if it's a list
of things right like the list of choices
or those answers it would call them
question underscore list to override
this we provide the context underscore
object underscore name attribute so we
override it and we give it our own name
if we didn't give it our own name we'd
have to access it using question or
score list but by giving it our own name
now we can access it on our template
side as latest question list okay
specifying that we want to use latest
question list instead as an alternative
approach you could change your templates
to match the new default context
variables but it's a lot easier to just
tell Jango to use a variable that you
want run the server and your new polling
app based on generic views so let's
actually give it a try
my server is indeed running I'm gonna
refresh I'll take a vote and it voted
correctly I'll vote for the sky and it
looks like it votes correctly I will go
to the polls like home page just polls
and it shows me all the detail views for
all of them right what's new and when I
go on what's up not only does it show me
the detail view but it also shows me the
choices that go along with it
so working fan in a fantastic way
write your first jingle app part 5 so
what are we doing in this tutorial we
aren't going to be doing a lot of
automated testing ok so what the hell is
automated testing well here let me break
it down in a simple easy-to-understand
way for you mere mortals out there let's
say you have something like Amazon write
something giant with millions of lines
of code are you really gonna like every
time you add a new feature are you gonna
test all of the older features to make
sure that they're working correctly
probably not it's gonna take up a lot of
your time plus you're gonna kill
yourself so what you're gonna do is
actually write these automated tests so
every time you add a new feature to
Amazon let's say that you add this new
cool feature that recommends new shoes
you want to make sure that the ability
when user clicks Add to Cart that still
works when the user clicks checkout that
still works so what you would normally
do is go and manually test it except
because Amazon is so big you're not
gonna be doing that so you're gonna
write automated test I'll test all of
those things every time you add a new
feature so when you add a new feature it
automatically tests everything that was
before it that's the point
of testing okay that's kind of the
beautiful thing about it okay so why you
need to create tests tests will save you
time yep it will save you a lot of time
because let's say you were to run into a
bug or someone unexpected behavior you
will know exactly why it's happening or
you'll catch on to it a lot faster if
you have code that tests those things as
you go along rather than waiting till
everything breaks the whole world comes
falling down and then you're like wait
what went wrong yeah good luck finding
the bug in your millions of lines of
code right you want a quality test each
thing as it comes in tests don't just
identify problems they prevent them okay
so this helps you identify any
problematic new bugs that could be
coming in and not only like identified
them but prevent them before it even
happens almost think of testing kind of
like if you just hired people without
interviewing
them I mean you wouldn't know right you
would hire people like this guy and you
would have people who you would have no
control over don't know and like let's
say something was going wrong in your
company you're not gonna know who to
blame because you never really tested
any person right but if you run through
an interview or a test with them then
oftentimes you don't even have to hire
them and you can kind of prevent it
before that problem spreads or if
they're awesome then you can add them in
right to your company tests also make
your code more attractive so basically
like your code will look nice if you
have tests otherwise developers won't
take you seriously and test how teams
work together so if your team is working
and some complex applications will be
maintained by teams write and test
guarantee that colleagues don't
inadvertently break your code and that
you don't break theirs without knowing
so this way it also helps when you get
employed and you have a job you know
it'll help you identify like where the
problem is coming from and the people
who are working with you on your team
they know exactly what you're thinking
and it won't cause problems in your code
either so those are the benefits of
testing now you have some basic testing
strategies something called a
test-driven development it's a pretty
common thing it's called TDD TDD okay
and basically it's like testing as you
go rather than wait till I write my
millions of lines of code and then
freaking test it right
wait till I have 30 employees and then
I'll ask them and interview them and
find out like don't do that test as you
go okay and now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna write our first test so oh
we identify a bug whoo look at that
well they're purposely planted a bug in
our code and now we're gonna use testing
to solve it okay we're gonna go Sherlock
Holmes
alright so fortunately there's a little
bug in the pols application for us to
fix right away the question was
published recently so you guys remember
that a little method we had was
published recently in our
models for question well it had a little
bug and basically how it works is the
method returns true if the question was
published within the last day which is
correct so if it was within the last 24
hours
it shows you true but it also shows you
true if it was published in the future
okay so it shouldn't say that it's
recent if it was gonna happen in the
future right you wouldn't say oh I
recently got a car if you're gonna get a
car 20 years from now when you finally
get a job right so I'm just kidding you
probably already have a job I don't
let's continue do check if the bug
really exists using the admin create a
question whose date lies in the future
and check the method check and check the
method using the shell so first we're
gonna check what's going on using the
shell alright so let's go back to our
code alright so the first thing we're
gonna do is run our Python so we're we
gonna run that from we're gonna do
Python manage that py shell don't just
do Python and it hit enter like an idiot
like I kind of did so once you run the
Python with this particular shell then
what happens is you can like import your
you know models and everything ok so now
import daytime we're gonna do from
django utils import timezone and then
we're gonna do from pols dot models
import wash the on with that said now
we're gonna create a question instance
with the publication date thirty days in
the future okay so how does this work
we're gonna create a variable called
future question and we're gonna create
it from the question class and we will
say the pub date is equal to timezone
dot now so we're saying that it's
published right now and then but to that
time zone dot now we're gonna add some
time to it okay so we're gonna do
daytime dot time Delta and we will do
days is equal to thirty just like that
okay and now we're gonna hit enter so
what I say I'm saying is like
right now plus 30 days which in other
words translates 30 days from now right
so basically right now where I am at and
what my current day for me is February
20th
okay 2018 so it's gonna do February 20th
plus 30 days after February 20th okay so
no it's not gonna be February 50th it's
gonna be March something right cool was
it published recently now we're gonna
ask it and it should say no it's not
published recently right it should
return false except that it returns true
so well there you have it we know that
something with our code is broken right
so since things in the future are not
recent this is clearly wrong
now we're gonna create a test to expose
the bug so right now we expose the bug
through the command line right we just
use to interact terminal shell but like
you don't want to be doing that every
single time you also don't want to be
doing that manually every single time so
we're gonna write a test for it they'll
automatically test it for us okay cool
so now we're gonna go into our test file
and write this code and then I'll kind
of break it down so in our under our
polls app we're gonna go into our tests
and we will paste this guy here okay I
copied over everything and I pasted it
over it so what's going on we're
importing daytime just like we did in
the shell or importing timezone you're
importing test case and we're importing
the question model from our models and
how is this working the class is we're
calling a question model test so the
good idea is like every time you want to
test a model make a class for that test
okay so this way it's nice and organized
this class inherits from test case
that's coming from here you kind of put
that in without really thinking about it
okay just like look about the Django
Doc's is saying and they just like
follow it on along it's not necessary
for you to like learn about this test
case class and how it's being inherited
and like get a PhD in it you can but
it's
necessary and then for your the name of
the function that you're testing you
wanna a good practice you want to like
break each thing you're testing have a
function for that particularly right so
for example if I go into my models I
have a method called was published
recently so since we want to test that
specific method under that class look
I'm doing test was published recently
right and name the test make it pretty
specific so somebody who's reading your
test method or your test function should
kind of know what it's supposed to do
just from reading the name so we're
testing was published recently but would
the future question so what if the
question was like published 30 days in
advance right here's a documentation for
it was published recently returns false
for questions whose publication date is
in the future cool that's what it's
supposed to do except it doesn't do that
so now we're checking this okay we're
saying hey set the time to 30 days from
now that's what this is doing and then
we make the future question just from
question class and then we set the
publication date to that particular time
from here line 16 and then on line 18
we're just saying hey assert if this is
this however this turns to true as we
saw earlier right like right here so
this is gonna this whole thing one if
you run it right now is gonna turn to
true and that's really the problem that
we're having right and we need to fix
that or our tests will expose it how do
we run our test we're just gonna go to
our command line we're gonna do Python
manage that py test polls so I'm gonna
exit out of this exit and now I will
simply do Python manage py test polls so
what I'm saying is like test a poll zap
and then it'll automatically basically
run the tests are py file inside of the
polls app that you created
run it and look it says failed failures
is equal to one
and basically it says assertion error it
tried this line solved at assert is and
what it found out was this was not this
and so its assertion error and it says
true is not false now if this whole
thing evaluated to false which is it's
supposed to then it would go false as
false and then this thing would return
true and it would throw any errors okay
now as you have more and more tests in
here all you'll have to do is just run
that once or you can set up a where
where it runs that once automatically
and that way you'll only alert you if
something is broken otherwise they'll
just go silently that's the beauty of
tests by the way have you guys ever
heard that song fly me to the moon by
Frank Sinatra can't stop thinking about
it's like playing in my head non-stop
anyways let's continue so what happened
is this Python managed that py test
polls looked for tests in the polls
application and explained that to
already it found a subclass of the
Django that has a test case subclass it
created a special database for the
purpose of testing if I go here look it
says destroying test database so it
created its own database from what was
happening right now it looked for test
method once whose ones whose names begin
with tests okay so it's looking for
everything that starts with tests if you
don't have these starting with tests it
won't find it okay so like let's just
say it was like this and I'll hit save
and then we'll also run this test pulls
and it didn't even find it it said it
ran zero tests in zero seconds but as
soon as I do that and if I run it boom
ran it created a in tests was published
recently with future class it created a
question instance whose publication
field is thirty days in the future right
over here and using the assert is method
discovered that it was published
recently returns true though we wanted
to return false what we found out here
cool
test informs us which has failed and
even the line on which the failure
occurred so here it'll tell us which
line we failed on line 18 right this is
line 18 cool so now we're gonna go ahead
and fix this bug how are we gonna fix it
well this is the code that's gonna help
us fix it we already know what the
problem is amend the method in models
rpy so it will return true of the date
is also in the past so we're gonna go
into models and we will change this to
this indentation and white space and
python is important so make sure it's
indented correctly underneath this was
published recently method and basically
we're saying hey set the timezone to now
like exactly right now and then subtract
one day from now if that's less than or
equal to the publish and check if that's
less than or equal to the self dot
publish date okay so if that's less than
or equal to the publish date and then
check if cells that published it is less
than or equal to now okay so in other
words check that this publication date
is in between this and this does that
make sense it has to be sandwiched
between the two and run the test again
so now I'm gonna hit save and I will
simply run the test again and now look
it says ran one test and it gave me an
OK and it's saying destroying the
database so cool it looks like it had no
errors it ran all the tests successfully
if it showed me something red or said
failures I'd know something failed so
now it's working cool now we can also do
after identifying a bug we wrote a test
that exposes it and corrected the bug in
the code
so our test passes many other things
might go wrong with our application in
the future but we can be sure that we
want inadvertently reintroduced this bug
so it'll automatically keep checking it
and we're not gonna be reintroducing
this bug because we'll always find it
because simply running the test will
warn us immediately we can consider this
little portion of the application pinned
down safely
forever pretty cool I think that's
pretty freaking cool and now they're
like alright we're gonna get into some
more comprehensive tests while we're
here we can further pin down the was
published recently method in fact it
would be positively embarrassing if in
fixing one bug we had introduced another
cool add two more test methods to the
same class to test the behavior of the
method more comprehensively so now we're
gonna test was we're gonna test the was
published recently method with old
question and then we're also gonna test
it with recent question and we already
have the future question so you can only
have three cases future question recent
question or old question if a question
is older than one day it should
basically say that it's not um if the
question is older than one day it will
should return false
it should say it's not recent if it's in
the future it should say it's not recent
if it's been posted less than one day
then it should say it's recent so for
example if we just look at this test
code at a high level old question
look it's asked its making sure that
it's asserting to be false so if it's
one day and one second ago right so if
it's one if it's exactly one day ago
then what it should do is it should say
yes it's still true but if it's one day
and one second ago now it should say
it's too late and it should
be considered false okay it should be
considered not recent and then published
recently with recent or with recent
question so if the question is as you
can see here not even one day ago 23
hours 59 minutes and 59 seconds ago
almost one day it should assert it to be
true okay take these and we will go into
our tests and we will add this into our
tests okay there we go 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
and 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 or 1 2 3 4
ok so just make sure that it's all
indented correctly and then that's you
should be good there so now we have all
of those scenarios covered future old or
recent question let's run our test and
let's see if we have any bugs no bugs it
looks like our method is working
perfectly
ok just so you understand this code
right here it'll only return true when
the publication date is in between this
and that ok so this is basically saying
it's within one day and this is saying
it's less than now ok so if this is in
between it'll match and now we have 3
tests that confirm the question was
published recently returned sensible
values for past recent future questions
good again polls is a simple application
but however complex it grows in the
future and whatever other code interacts
would we now have some guarantee that
the method we have written tests for
will behave in expected ways test of
view so you can also test views the
polls application is fair
undiscriminating it will publish any
question including ones whose
publication date field lies in the
future we should improve this setting a
publication date in the future should
mean of the questions published at that
moment but invisible until then alright
so what are we doing here well when we
post our question if it's some data in
the future it shouldn't show it just
like for example on WordPress if you
publish a blog post for let's say you
know two days later it doesn't show
until two days later right you can
schedule your post or on YouTube
sometimes I schedule my videos and you
know I'll say show this video to the
audience in one week from now right so
if I do show it from one week from now
it shouldn't be showing it at that same
time that would be crazy
that wouldn't make sense just like that
we also want to do with our questions
and make sure that it doesn't just show
out of nowhere and we want to make a
test for a view when we fix that but
above we wrote the test first and then
the code to fix it in fact that was a
simple example of test-driven
development but it doesn't really matter
in which order we do the work in our
first test we focus closely on the
internal behavior of the code for this
test we want to check its behavior as it
would be experienced by a user through a
web browser okay so the first one it was
like the logic of the code this one
we're focusing on what happens if the
user is like testing it and the user is
actually on the front end of the website
what does it show to them and isn't that
cool that you can automatically test
that every time your code runs and you
don't have to like go and check if your
cart is working or your blog is showing
things like that all right so the Django
tests client so here's a command we're
gonna go in our command line and type in
so I'm gonna copy this guy again and
remember we got to do Python manage that
py shell then paste this guy and then we
will get set up test environment just
like that okay installs a template
renderer which will allow us to bla bla
bla bla bla
okay we will get this guy and then also
they say something about timezone so
make sure your timezone is correct mine
is in America / Los Angeles if I go in
my settings and show you for you it
might be something different so you can
go in this go to this link and look up
what your timezone is okay so we're
gonna import the client and then we're
gonna create an instance of the client
so here we're creating an instance and
now we can get a response from our home
page now when the response from your
home page should give you something like
not found or a 404 it's because if you
go to your home page there's nothing
there right if you just go to right now
your localhost 127 dot 0 dot 0 dot 1
colon 8,000 it should give you an error
the only routes that are mapped is like
if you go to slash admin or if you go to
slash pols remember that so that's why
the home is giving us a 404 right now we
should expect a 404 from that address
let's just do response dot status code
and here it is 404 we should expect to
find something at polls though ok so
let's try that we'll use reverse rather
than a hard-coded URL so instead of
doing like you know whatever slash polls
we're gonna just do a reverse here okay
so from Django we're gonna import
reverse and we'll paste this guy right
here and now if we do response that
status code it shows me something if I
do response it's saying template
response status code is 200 and it's a
text slash HTML file which it is okay
and now we can also get the content we
can do response that content so now it's
showing me the content of that file and
if you remember we do have unordered
list in the start and
then we have bullet points so here you
have what's cracking in HTML to show an
apostrophe they have to do this
ampersand number sign 39 semicolon
that's basically apostrophe and we also
have our other question what's new and
you can see their links here as well
okay so this is like just showing the
code version of what the user or we
actually see on the front end and we can
also do response a context and get the
latest question list and look it gave us
the questions what's cracking what's new
what's up now we can improve our view as
well the list of pulls the the list of
poll shows polls that aren't published
yet those that have publication date in
the future let's fix that so right
that's a problem so we need to fix that
we introduced a class based view based
on list view so we're gonna go ahead and
fix things in there now we need to amend
it so let's go up to our views and our
index view we need to fix this and
change it so that it also checks the
date by comparing it with timezone dot
now first we need to add an import so at
the top of our code we're gonna add this
here import timezone and then our query
set we're gonna change it a bit so where
is our query set
all right can we put this on one line so
it looks slightly less confusing yeah we
were fine we're not following Pep eight
we're running across a little bit but
according to my boy Raymond the og
Hettinger or head injure you know
according to him he says 1995 characters
should be good enough
Pep 8 I think with the whole edy
character line is kind of stupid because
honestly breaking this down into new
lines messes up to code readability but
right now this looks pretty easy to read
if you just have it much easier if you
just have it on one line anyway okay
what is it doing it returns the last
five published questions not including
those set to be published in the future
all right so how is it doing that it's
taking the questions model it's finding
all the objects and it's filtering those
objects and only finding the following
okay
this statement here it's looking at the
publication date and it's only finding
so this underscore underscore LT means
you're doing a reverse search and you're
saying less than or equal to that's what
LTE means less than or equal to so any
publication date that was less than or
equal to the current time meaning only
past or current posts filter those and
then once we find those we order those
by descending publication date so which
one was the most recent ones and then we
show the first five that's it okay
a lot going on and now we can also test
our new view so now you can satisfy
yourself that this behaves as expected
by firing up the run server loading the
site in your browser creating questions
with dates in the past and future and
checking that only those that have been
published or listed you don't want to
have to do that every single time you
make a change that might affect this so
let's create a test based on our shell
session above sea shells see what is it
see she sells seashells down the
seashore okay that's a falling to pull
slash test that py polls TAS
all right we're adding reverse boom and
we'll create a shortcut function to
create questions as well as a new test
class so this will create questions for
us cool since this is not gonna be a
method it's gonna be a function we're
gonna put it outside like that
this will create questions how will it
create questions you give it a question
text and you give it days and then what
it does is it'll create a question with
that number of days in the future or
with that number of days in the past
based on whether you pass in a positive
number here or a negative number here or
something like zero okay right here and
then it goes into question that object
and it creates that object in questions
class and for the question tax keyword
argument it passes in question text and
for the pub date keyword argument it
passes in the time which it gets from
here cool cool okay so question view
index what are we doing there question
view question index view test so we're
creating a new class here so I'm gonna
go right there and paste it and save so
now we're creating tests for our index
view
instead of model okay so this is our
model test and what we're saying is like
tests no questions if no question exists
inappropriate and appropriate message is
displayed so if I go into my views and
you can see in my views let's see it's
there is it not there or is it an RHD I
yeah I think it's in our HTML right
index so here you can see it says if
there are recent questions and show them
else say no polls are available so we
want to test that it actually does say
no polls are available on our front end
we can actually do that and right here
and we say hey first check that the
status code for this page is a 200
meaning that you actually find this page
second test at that response that you
find it contains no polls are available
ok so right now remember we have no
questions at the moment and then also
make sure that the cert query set is
equal to the response is equal to the
following so this thing latest question
list should be empty that makes sense
right that means there are no questions
so it's just a no polls are available
and it should check that this is
actually just an empty list cool now
what we want to do is test past
questions okay again this could go on
could this go on one line or this will
be too crazy this is pretty crazy so I
can I can break that up a little bit
that's fine still readable for me okay
so we're saying if we create a question
okay again this creates its own database
so it doesn't have our what's cracking
and whatever tests available anymore for
these tests it creates its own database
and then it destroys that database
afterward so within this database we're
creating a question and the question
text will be called past question
instead of what's cracking or what's
poppin or whatever and we're gonna say
that it should be dirty it should have
been created 30 days ago okay so this is
a past question
hence test past question and then what
we're gonna say is hey response get that
particular page and once we get that
page we want to say hey is that are the
latest questions of that page contain
that question and the answer will be yes
it does because we just created it right
here and if this thing is equal to this
then the test should pass we're also
gonna create a future question so this
should test a question thirty days in
the future pretty much the same thing
and make sure the response contains no
polls are available that makes sense
right because if the question is in the
future then it shouldn't be available
right now so I should say no polls are
available and also make sure that the
response that context latest question is
empty because there are no latest
questions it's gonna be posted in the
future okay cool and let's check this
guy with the recent and past questions
again I think it's a little bit more
readable like that you can break it down
like this that should be fine too but I
like it like this and basically what
we're testing here is that this thing
should equal to this thing
and what's going on here the dock for
this as this is test future question and
pass question even if both past and
future questions exist only past
questions are displayed that makes sense
too and how does it work we create a
question 30 days in the past we create a
question 30 days in the future question
one is called past question question two
is called future question we get the
pols index page and then we say that
this thing the latest question list
should only have the past question those
created 30 days ago and not the recent
question and it should match that and
indeed and it should right if we did
everything right we shouldn't get an
error if we run this and then what we
need to do is define two past questions
all right now this is getting a little
too big so let's break this one down now
and you can indent this too
okay so what am I saying here I'm saying
so test two past questions so the
questions index page may display
multiple questions so we also want to
see that it doesn't just display one
question it displays multiple ones right
so we have past question one which was
create 30 days ago we have past question
two which was created five days ago we
get the polls index page and then we say
make sure that the question list
actually let's do it like this because I
think it'll more readable actually so
you want to say that this should equal
to this okay latest question list should
have both of the past questions why in
this order because remember the most
recent ones it shows it first right if
we look at our views and how it does it
ascending order sorry descending order
and then the five so that's why that's
why I would show the past question too
first and then this one right here cool
basically the most recent question is
just show all the way at the top all
right so first is a question shortcut
function create question to take some
repetition yeah well we pretty much went
over this whole thing so we don't have
to check that and so on in effect we are
using the test to tell a story of admin
input and user experience on the site
and checking that at every state and for
every new change in the state of the
system the expected results are
published now that's a really important
point like you're telling a story with
your test guys like this is what's
really important to understand so if
you're working on a team with somebody
and somebody's reading through your
tests they understand what each of your
view is supposed to do and what it's
supposed to return like so so so key
like if I'm looking at somebody's code I
don't know what the hell it's supposed
to do right I don't know what the right
answer is supposed to be but if I look
at their test and they have like bunch
of examples and what the correct answer
and the wrong answer should be and that
documentation I totally understand what
each function is supposed to do what
each class is supposed to do and then
effectively I'm on the same page and
then I can actually contribute to this
project right I can go that's where you
guys hear like hey just go ahead and
contribute to open source projects this
is one of the ways that you can do that
understand look at their tests first and
then like I can't tell you enough for
those of you who are a little bit more
advanced to understand the library
here's a protip one of the best ways to
do it is not just like instead of just
reading the code go and look at their
tests and they will have so many things
in there and what it's supposed to do
you'll start understanding how this
libraries supposed to work and it's how
supposed to behave literally tells a
story now we want to test the detail
view okay so what we have works well
however even though future questions
don't appear in the index users can
still reach them if they know or guess
the right URL so we need to add a
similar constraint to detail view okay
so we don't want to our users to be able
to reach those questions obviously
because they don't exist so they
shouldn't just be able to go to that
particular URL okay like let's say you
had a blog post like whatever your blog
post is called banana so it's like John
calm slash blog slash banana
if you scheduled it for like a month
later I shouldn't be able to just go to
it from the URL okay so what's going on
here we have the detailed view so let's
go into our reviews let's go into our
detail view it's right here what did I
want us to do they want us to create a
query set and do this with it okay
excludes any questions that aren't
published yet so filter make sure the
publication date is less than or equal
to then the time zone dot now
that's that's it that's essentially it
and those are the only ones you can
check pretty cool okay
very very powerful again you can see how
powerful the generic method is and of
course we will add some tests to check
that a question whose publication date
is in the past can be displayed and now
one with a publication date in the
future is not so let's go into our tests
and let's an add the test for this so
again it's a new class it should have
its own methods and everything right so
for the index view we created a class
okay for those tests and now for our
detailed views we're also creating a
class okay very important now we test
future question and we test past
question how do we do that we create the
question five days in advance we send
you to the polls detail page so like for
example an Instagram if you click into a
image and it shows you that specific
image that's equivalent in our app of
polls detail or questions detailed view
and for the arguments we give it that
questions ID from right here and as a
response we get that particular URL and
then we say hey make sure that the
response actually returns a 404 and it
will because here's how we told it and
then test pass question so basically
here we're saying 404 meaning it doesn't
exist right so the detailed view of a
question of the publication did in the
past displays the questions text so past
question we created the question here it
was created five days ago
we get the URL for the poles detail and
we pass on the ID for the past question
and then as a response we get that
specific URL and then we assert and make
sure that it can the response contains
the following thing so a response and
then it should have the question text in
there okay it's a past question question
text cool and let's see let us let's see
if we're gonna be using any more command
line stuff we're not so let's go an exit
and let's just see right now if our
tests are working in our poll slash view
something is happening on line 18 what
is happening ah okay it's not indented
correctly obviously save up and enter
and look at that all our tests ran in
here and they all ran successfully so
you can see if all these tests have
already gotten pretty complicated and
they're testing our app pretty
thoroughly you know this is not
something you want to do manually every
single time and you can already see the
power of it
all right ideas for more tests so we
have to add similar query set method to
results view and create a new test class
for that view so we can also test
results view it'll be very similar to
what we have just created in fact there
will be a lot of repetition we could
also improve our application and other
ways adding tests along the way for
example it's silly that questions can be
published on the site that have no
choices so our views could check for
this and exclude such questions our
tests could create a question without
choice and then test that it's not
published as well as create a similar
question with choices and tests that it
is published also you can have logged in
admin users who should be allowed to see
and publish questions but like ordinary
visitors shouldn't be so if you're an
admin right and you have WordPress blog
and you schedule one in advance you can
see it but other people can't just like
I can't schedule my YouTube videos you
can't see it I can whatever needs to be
added to the software to accomplish this
should be accompanied by a test whether
you write the test first and then make
the code pass the test this is a the
test-driven way of doing it or work out
the logic in your code first and then
write a test to prove it at a certain
point you're bound to look at your test
and wonder whether your code is
suffering from test bloat which brings
us to the following so the thing that
they say is when testing more is
actually better okay so it might seem
that your test is going out of control
and there's a lot of like test bloat and
you know what you're beautiful
elegant and concise code compared to
your test looks so much better
that's totally okay tests are supposed
to be bulky in a lot and they should
cover your ass okay that's their job and
so they don't have to look pretty they
don't have to look beautiful they have
to tell a story and have to tell it
clearly so it doesn't matter right let
them grow and for the most part you can
write a test once and then forget about
it it will continue performing its
useful function as you continue to
develop your program sometimes they will
need to be updated just like we had to
update ours
telling us exactly which test needs to
be amended to bring you up to date so
that extent tests help look after
themselves at worst as you continue
developing you might find that you have
some tests that are redundant in testing
redundancy is actually a good thing
and even that redundancy is not a
problem okay so the more you test the
better and you don't have to go back and
wipe anything clean as long there
sensibly arranged they won't become
unmanageable okay so the good rules of
thumbs good rules of thumb include the
following you should have a separate
test class for each model or view so for
remember for each of our models right
our question model question model test
we had a different class for this and
for each of our views we actually had a
different class for a detail view we had
a different class for our index view and
if you wanted to go further we could
also add a different class for our
results view a separate test method for
each set of conditions you want to test
so instead of testing tests no questions
test pass question and kind of like
testing it all in one it's a good idea
to break it down into separate different
tests each test doing only one job so
here if no questions exist an
appropriate message displayed that's
what this is test is supposed to do this
test over here questions with a
publication date in the past are
displayed on the end especially you can
see each each test is trying to do one
and one thing only okay
test method names that describe their
function so the names themselves should
describe the function of the test okay
so test no questions test pass questions
test future questions and once you build
this naming convention you and your team
starts understanding it and most of the
times you guys will be able to just look
at each other tests and know what your
app is supposed to be doing or what it's
not supposed to be doing further testing
this tutorial only introduces some of
the basics of test
there's a great deal more that you can
do and a number of very useful tools at
your disposal to achieve some very
clever things for example so this is a
pretty cool part right now we just kind
of tested our back-end and a little bit
of our front-end but what if we wanted
to test our JavaScript and how it loads
and literally like moving the mouse like
have the computer move the mouse and
select one of the votes and click vote
how does that experience work how can we
test that on autopilot where it happens
automatically well there's something
called saleem selenium or selenium and
it's a way to test your HTML actually
renders in a browser okay so these tools
allow you to check not just a behavior
of your Django code but also for example
of your JavaScript and your browser
pretty freaking mind-blowing it's quite
something to see the tests launch a
browser and start interacting with your
site as if a human being were driving it
and Django includes live server test
case to facilitate integration with
tools like selenium okay so if you want
to get more advanced look up Django and
selenium and you could even look up
YouTube videos online and add those kind
of tests within your app if you have a
complex application you may want to run
tests automatically with every commit
for the purposes of continuous
integration so if you guys know about
github and commits you can make it so
that when you're writing the code and as
soon as you commit it
I like to call it like the time machine
because that's what get in version
control allows you to do you can make it
so then it tests it on every commit so
that if any one of your commits you know
fails any of the tests it'll be like hey
this is broken and you'll find out right
away before you actually push that code
on to github and destroy your life
embarrass yourself let down your family
and be fired from your job so that
quality control it is itself at least
partially automated a good way a good
way to spa untested parson wrapper
is to check code coverage this also
helps identify fragile or even dead code
if you can't test a piece of code it
usually means that code should be
refactored or removed that's those are
some big words coverage will help to
identify that code see integration of
coverage that py and you can check you
know what's dead code and what's not and
yeah so a lot of testing I hope that you
enjoyed that
we're gonna be covering essentially how
static files it work in Django okay and
how you can use them to customize your
apps look and feel okay so without any
further ado let's jump right into it
okay so writing your first app part 6
right so how what are we doing now now
we've built a tested web poll
application if you haven't done that go
back to part 5 if you haven't done part
5 go back to fart part 4 make sure
you're following this in order and now
will now add a stylesheet and an image
ok so aside from HTML that your app
generates right and shows which is you
know your front-end so far the voting
thing that we have or it shows some text
with radio buttons your website needs to
be able to do other things to like show
people images or pictures of cats or
blog post images it also needs to be
able to serve up JavaScript if you have
any JavaScript right so for example if
you don't know JavaScript is it's
totally fine but like any time you're
clicking a button and it like pops up a
menu kind of thing that's usually
JavaScript going on there ok
if you click something like a pop-up
comes up that's JavaScript JavaScript is
pretty much everywhere so your website
needs to be able to show some JavaScript
and it also needs to be able to serve
CSS ok which is it's called Cass stands
for cascading style sheet and you use
this to stylize your app and make it
look cool and beautiful ok and yeah so
that's usually what's necessary to
complete a web page in Django we refer
to these files as static files now for
small projects right this isn't a big
deal because you can just keep the
static file somewhere where your web
server can find it
however in bigger projects especially
those comprised of like multiple apps
right so if you have multiple apps like
polls and blog and e-commerce like
whatever dealing with the multiple sets
of static files provided but each
application starts to get tricky
that's why Django dot contributed static
files is there for you if you're a
beginner don't worry about this part too
much but this is for more advanced
people mentioning this part okay
otherwise I'd kind of skip over it it
collects static files from each of your
applications and any other places you
specify into a single location that can
be that can easily be served in
production okay so now let's get to
customizing your apps look and feel so
first we're gonna need to create a
directory called static in your polls
directory okay so let's go ahead and do
that I'm gonna open up atom and we will
go in our polls hopefully you can see
that on the left hand side I don't know
how to make that bigger so I'm sorry
about that
but yeah we're gonna go inside of our
polls and inside of our polls I think
this is where it wants us to make it so
I'm gonna right click this polls not the
templates one so right right click here
create a new folder and call it static
done okay cool
and for those of you wondering like how
do I switch like that it's command + tab
and on Windows that's Alt + tab
cool Django will look for static files
there similarly to how Django finds
templates inside polls temple poll slash
templates so you know how there's like
poll slash templates and Django
automatically looks for templates there
well just like that for your static
files Django is gonna look inside of
your folder static okay so Django static
file setting contains a list of finders
and know how to discover static files
from various sources one of the defaults
is AB directories finder which looks for
a static subdirectory in each of the
installed apps
okay so jingle will automatically look
for a folder called static under each of
the installed apps ok so right now we
have polls as one of our apps that we
created and remember to install this app
we had to do this line in our settings
file understand stalled apps
and then now Django is able to find its
static folder if you have another app
again like a blog app and you have
static folder under there and you
install the blog app then you'll be able
to then Django will be able to find the
blog's blog apps static files okay like
images JavaScript CSS those are all
considered static files all right the
admin uses the same directory structure
for its static files cool so admin site
works the same way with in the static
directory you have just created a create
another directory called polls so inside
of static we're gonna create another
directory and we're going to call it
pulls okay so kind of like how you have
polls templates polls you're gonna have
polls static polls okay similar and then
inside of here we're gonna create a file
called styles that CSS I'm gonna do new
file and I'll do style dot CSS just like
that okay so this is our CSS again in
the command line if you haven't
activated your virtual environment make
sure to do kondeh or sorry source
activate my sites if you haven't done
that just in case you need to do
something in the command line which
you're not gonna in this video I don't
think because of how the app directories
Finder static files finder works you can
refer to this data file in Django simply
as pole slash styles as CSS similar to
how you reference the path for templates
so remember how for templates you just
go pull slash index dot HTML well for
this is pull slash style dot CSS okay
and for name spacing it's just like
templates so the same reason why you put
templates under of the same reason why
you make a new folder called polls under
templates is the same reason why you
create a another folder called polls
under static it's so then if you have
multiple different apps there's no
collision based on like you
having the same name for any of your CSS
files or any of your HTML files that's
what they're saying here okay now we're
gonna do some fun CSS stuff okay and
we're gonna keep it pretty simple so in
our style that CSS what I'm basically
saying is that any link tag under a
bullet point or a listed thing color it
green okay so a stands for like a is
like your link tags anything that
contains a link basically returning for
now we're turning almost all of our
links on our current site green next add
the following at the top of polls slash
templates slash polls slash index dot
HTML so we're gonna go in our templates
pulls index dot HTML and at the top what
we're gonna add is we're gonna say low
static so we're gonna add that right
here load static so what this is now
able to do is load our static files and
then right here I'm gonna add this so
I'm created I'm creating a link to a
stylesheet the type is text slash CSS
and the link is this now I'm using the
link in a dynamic way this is the best
way to link it instead of like hard
coding the actual path and you just say
polo slash style dot CSS okay that's how
we refer to it and that's pretty much it
okay so now let's go to our website so
I'm gonna do Python manage that py run
server and we're gonna open up a new tab
and I'm gonna go 127 that's slash 8,000
or I'm sorry slash pulls and you can see
that all the links are green right if I
go back to my stylesheet and turn it
into something else
so let's go back into sorry style dot
CSS is right there I'll bring it here if
I change this to like blue save command
go back here refresh you can see that
all of this is now blue if your didn't
turn blue clothes out of your server
break the server with ctrl C and then
try it again and it should be fixed and
yep there we go
and also make sure to save okay and
another way to go to this same link is
doing HTP localhost colon 8080 cue
localhost colon 8080
do the same thing all right so that's
essentially how we got that to work this
guy here
now we also can add a background image
okay so we'll create a subdirectory for
images create an images subdirectory so
basically inside of our static and polls
we're gonna create static holes we're
gonna create a new directory and we're
gonna call it images this is we're gonna
put all up all of our images so it
should look like this and then you can
put whatever image you want right
background gif or so what we'll do is
we'll go online and like grab an image
so let's get cats right click and then
just save the image and you can save it
whatever you want you're gonna call it
like cat background oh sorry we can't
just save it wherever we want I'm gonna
save it under my site my site or sorry
pulls static pulls images and I'm gonna
save this cat underscore background and
it's automatically a jpg file because I
have the format selected like that I'm
gonna hit save it saved I'm gonna open
up my atom and under images I now have
my cat background JPEG so let's go back
to this tutorial and it's basically
saying to do this add this to your
stylesheet
so I'm gonna add this now I'm gonna say
so from images instead of background
jiff mine is called cat underscore
background add JPEG like that so now and
it's gonna find basically in our HTML
code it's gonna find anywhere we have
the body tag it's gonna make its
background this cat image okay so if I
go to you know our index dot HTML if any
of this stuff is in a body tag it'll add
that to the background so let's check it
out it says and you should see the
background loaded in the top left of the
screen okay let's give it a try let's
see if they're in line and there you go
it's there right so pretty cool how it
works and what I could also do is I
could go to my index.html and like wrap
maybe a certain part of it in the body
tag so like maybe the part that's in the
for loop right so I can I can go like
body tag and I can choose to close the
body tag outside of this unordered list
I can go body like that okay if I want
to and I go back i refresh and the same
thing okay so this is essentially like a
little bit of how HTML and CSS like talk
with each other okay and now let's look
at kind of their last notes here so
there okay so warning of course the
static template tag is not available for
use in static files like your style
sheet which earned generated by Django
so in your CSS file you can't use
something like static like that it's not
gonna know what that is and you can't do
like if-then statement
here these are just your static files
hence they're not dynamic and can't do
like variables and cool stuff right like
your index your HTML file can with the
which has a Django template exist 'm and
in there you should always use relative
pets so here we're not using like slash
user slash clever programmer slash
github slash my site slash my site or
slash pols slash what else is it static
slash pull slash images right we're not
using the absolute path that's the
definition of absolute pet we're using a
relative path to it to you're satisfied
between each other because then you can
change static underscore URL so this is
again a little bit more advanced I'm
gonna I'm gonna skip over this one you
can read that if you want and that's
essentially how you work with general
like static files on Django there you
have it folks
I hope you enjoyed this tutorial I hope
it was informative and juicy and you
loved it if you did love it please leave
a comment please like it and share it
with at least one friend because if you
have at least one friend or family
member
sorry what's happening with my mic if
you have one friend or one family member
who's doing development alongside you is
gonna boost your success rate up by at
least sixty percent they have like
scientific studies on this so share it
maybe somebody will watch it alongside
and you will become web developers
together